right
then oh well here we
go these things are sent to
triers is it no swearing there John we
are now live
CH thank you
John right good morning everybody good
morning those joining on YouTube good
morning to
everybody uh who's joined us on the zoom
meeting counselors and offices and
members of the public right
um I'd like to welcome you all to this
virtual meeting of the plans committee
I'll just go through a few basic rules
for this meeting at the start of the
meeting we will mute all microphones
except mine please leave all microphones
muted unless you asked by me to
speak residents who want to exercise
this right have all have been asked to
register in advance and also have had
the option of sending a statement to us
which will be read by an officer where
they've been sent a link to temporarily
join the meeting to speak in
person we've got uh 12 persons
registered to speak today we've we've
lost one application it's been withdrawn
uh the final one on the agenda has been
withdrawn but with 12 persons registered
to speak to indicate to me that you
would like to speak or propose or second
a motion please press the raise and
raise hand symbol in the participants
menu on your
screen these are shown on my screen in
the order that they are pressed and I'll
deal with them in order giving the
appropriate officer or counselor the
opportunity to answer in between where
necessary I will also return to the C
counselor to check that they're happy
with the
response to ensure Clarity and accuracy
during virtual meetings all votes cast
via a verbal recorded vote and names
will be read out in alphabetical order
this did does tend to slow the process
up a bit but it's the only way we can
get an accurate response from Members
please state that your vote your vote
clearly and slowly when your name is uh
read out
uh unmuting and muting your microphone
as necessary and please remember that to
ensure full transparency with the
Democratic process this meeting is being
live streamed on the council's YouTube
channel I ask you all to be patient
during this meeting and to understand
that processes and advice may take a
little longer than usual I'll now ask
each member of the committee to
introduce themselves um and also the
officers present who'll be taking part
during the meeting so Sandra if you're
there please could you read out in
alphabetical order please yes chair
thank you councelor bowon yeah I'm
Richard bowon I represent Harman
Ward councilor
Brown good morning I representing great
torington councelor Christie good
morning I represent bford
North councelor
craigy good morning I represent East the
water
bford councilor
leather yes good morning I represent nor
of
them councelor lock yes good morning I
represent two rivers and three
Moors councelor
mcgoff good morning I represent bord
North councelor Watson morning I
represent broad e and councelor wisan
hello I represent the chevier and lankry
Ward thank you chair now if the if the
officers would like to introduce
themselves starting with Sean Harrington
please good morning members good morning
members of the public my name is Sean
Harrington I'm the development manager
at Tor District
Council hi I'm Stacy Dory I'm the senior
sister and monitoring officer for torage
District
Council good morning Chris eely planning
off to
council good morning Laura Davis
principal planning
officer and we've got uh I think two
County Council officers
present come on Mike speak up good
morning Matt Collins Devon County
Council
highways and good morning Michael nukin
from Devon County Council Highway
always okay lovely thank you right now
on to our main agenda and item one on
the agenda is apologies for absence but
I think we've got a full house this
morning yes chair no
apologies thank you Sandra item two on
the agenda Pages 5 to 14 are the minutes
of the last meeting held on the 6th of
August
uh you've all had to read through those
minutes if somebody would like to
propose those
minutes if you're happy with the
accuracy of them councelor Watson are
you proposing them I I'll propose chair
thank you second and I will second them
thank you councelor lock uh that's been
proposed by Council of Watson seconded
by councilor wat Sandra could you read
through the members please yes chair
thank you councelor bowon at four
councelor
Brown
four councelor Christie four councelor
craigy four councelor leather four
councelor lock four councelor
mcof four councelor Watson four
councelor wisman four that's unanimous
chair thank you Sandra
right item three on the agenda is
Declarations of interests members with
interest to declare should refer to the
agenda item and describe the nature of
their interest when the item is being
considered elected members of Devon
County Council and town and Parish
councils who've considered a planning
application by virtue of their
membership of that Council hold a
personal interest and are deemed to have
considered the application separately
and the expressed views of that council
do not bind the members concerned who
consider the application
aresh and item four is agreement of the
agenda between Parts one and two there
is no part two but as I said at this at
the start the final application F warbly
1054 2019 full application Ruby Oak Park
Brandy corner holsworthy has been
withdrawn so
that that leaves us with five
today urgent matters item five
information brought forward with I have
no urgent matters to bring forward so uh
public participation the chair now will
advise the
committee uh of any prior request to
speak made by members of the public and
to advise the details of the council's
uh procedure for uh
public speaking well we've got 12
speakers we've got one two three the
first application there are four two
three four five speakers for there's
only one for the second application
there are one two two for the next
application uh two for the final
application sorry for the bramber
application and there are two for the
building at grid reference the
bradworthy one which
is lifting a condition application to
lift a condition okay councelor Christie
has a hand up councelor Christie yeah
thank you it was under urgent matters um
at the last planning meeting I did ask
uh if we could have a prey of the
government's new rules about planning
and also um some um idea about the heath
decision as well how it's going to
affect us uh can I ask how the officers
are getting on with that because I think
it is quite
important well sure yeah sh Sean will
answer that of course it is a
consultation document that white paper
but Sean can you answer councelor
Christie please I can counc thank you
councel Christie um I do have an update
on both the heo decision and the um a
brief update on the planning white paper
uh which will be subject to further
consultation with members I was going to
provide an update uh following this
meeting but I can do it now if members
wish to do
so well I think we better do it at the
end of the meeting we got quite long
agend we might not want to stay for
it is it a long presentation
Sean uh I mean people PE members may
want to discuss some of the things in it
that's the only thing that's going to
delay is getting on of the applications
we've got we've got people to speak at
these applications so I rather we do it
at the end actually councel a l I was
just going to say that if you got
members of the public be unfair to keep
them waiting we should at the end of the
meeting we'll do it at the end of the
meeting yeah uh okay right we move on
then um the order of speakers is as
follows to the planning applications the
planning officer will give their
presentation of the application then any
town or Parish Council who wish to speak
for or against the application they have
three minutes and then up to members of
the public who wish to speak against an
application they have three minutes each
and then there are two up to two members
of the public in support of an
application and they have three minutes
each and finally any torage council
member from the ward in which the
application Falls they don't have a time
limit they can speak on it as well and
then the plans committee will then
debate the application with any
questions they may have for the
appropriate
officer okay we we'll move on
then planning applications the
information recommendations and advice
contained in the reports are correct at
the date of preparation which is more
than 10 days in advance of the committee
meeting due to these time constraints
any changes or necessary updates to the
reports will be provided in writing or
orally at the committee
meeting and we move on then to our first
app
this morning coun lock has a hand up
councel loot yeah I just like to declare
um to say that be is in my ward I have
attended many beef and Paris Council
meetings and two open meetings in be
Village Hall where the application has
been discussed I have listened carefully
to all points made and at no stage have
I ever expressed my opinion on this
application as I wish to keep an open
and clear mind until all the relevant
information has been received and that
is now contained in the officer report
together with any latest update that the
officer may have to present to the
committee so I come to the meeting with
a clear and open
mind thank you for that Council a lot
because this is our first application
this morning application one oblique
0407 2019 a full
application for land at Marshalls me
beef it I think Christian eely our
planning officer is given this
presentation so over to you Christian
thank you chair um as you can see on the
screen this is a residential development
for 40 dwellings including the
demolition of one dwelling for the
creation of new access so overall it
will amount to the creation of 39
dwellings I
suppose there's a couple verbal object
uh a couple uh verbal updates firstly um
there's been eight new objections and
one neutral um summarized uh these can
be shown as follows so um one of the
objection s was actually a petition so
um they're saying or the obors are
saying that the total number is actually
86 rather than that stated in officer
report this is uh simply just a case of
how TDC register it but um yeah if you
count the peti each member of that
petition then yes that would be correct
the number of objections would be
86 and there are um further concerns
regarding highways and um Mike Nukem is
asked me just to um note that he's also
received um objections regarding parking
on the highway and um that this the
objections are stating that this
application would sterilize parking on
the road Frontage I'm sure we can
discuss this at a later date however he
claims that uh it will still be
acceptable and the adequate mitigation
has been provided and um I can go with
this uh statement um further objections
not size of development is
disproportionate to the Village there's
no set completion time so it could just
essentially take ages to be built out
and that there's um a breach of Human
Rights secondly there's an update
regarding um the contributions so um the
agent has confirmed um as um said said
in my officer report I would upate
update you that four affordable uh to
buy dwellings could be provided uh in Li
of the financial contributions set out
in the committee report we can discuss
these uh at a later date uh during the
committee and that would essentially be
up to members to prioritize um what they
want to take and what what they are what
their priorities are for the
site and then that's it for the update
so I'll move on to the presentation um
this is a site location plan uh you can
see it's uh beeford there you've got the
uh
a32 uh a312 for sorry uh there which the
road is accessed from that goes from
torington to
winkley and this uh this dwelling here
would would be the ding which has be to
be
demolished and the primary school is in
in there which you'll see in a
second this is the site location plan so
it comes in from the a31 124 um there's
some parking spaces at the entrance in
the form of U fish uh mitigation or
Village parking mitigation so they're
labeled as Village parking spaces and
then there's three bus spaces and fre
Mini Bus spaces uh there there'll be a
new access to the primary school at that
point and then as you travel around the
site there's a variety of dwellings uh
to the south of the site there's the
open
Countryside the the these two points
here will not be uh through roads into
existing developments of R park close
and Marshalls me so there'll just be
foot
paths and um that's about it for the
site as a a area of uh Village uh
greenop space in the center
there there's area location of the site
you can see it's um fairly Central in
the village but also borders open
Countryside
so the Bungalow to be demolished at the
entrance visibility looking right from
the proposed
entrance visibility to your
left existing primary schools to your
left and this is a junction going uh
into Green Lane uh that Junction is
considered
poor this is looking the other way um
the existing Primary School drop off off
uh on Green Lane is there and you can
see the primary school there uh where
that Ali
is this is rart close so as you travel
up Green Green Lane which we adjust that
you come in uh you come to a left hand
Junction and you can come down R par
close so you can see it's an existing
modern Bungalow style development and in
the distance there's a foot path which
travels through the
site so this is standing on that foot
path traveling through the site looking
back at R Park
Place this is a view for from the
footpath looking at the rear of where
the school playing fields are we're
about to essentially go around the site
in a clockwise Direction with
photographs so this is that uh site
towards Sur of the school so the new
entrance to the primary school would
come in
there this is a view of in the site
looking uh Northeast towards the a
3124 um if I just highlight
that this Bungalow here is the Bungalow
to be demolished and the access way will
come VI
that oh for some reason it isn't clear
let's clear that this is the rear of the
Bungalow to be
demolished um you can see that this
photo was taken at a different time
during the winter uh at when they were
Turf cutting but this is uh at the point
of the rear of bungalow looking along
neighboring
boundaries this is back from the foot
path looking uh at the Southeastern
boundary it's well established HED
row again moving clockwise looking
Southeast showing the footpath running
through the
site uh looking Southwest you can see
the new development in the background
known as as Marshall
me this is standing from within that
Gateway which was just zoomed into
looking viewing the new development
there's a proposed footpath link SL
emergency access which would link into
this new development um but that so that
would have a retractable Ballard um but
it generally wouldn't be open to the
public to use as a vehicle right of
way looking back from that field
entrance uh the other way back towards
rart
close again rart close
entrance um this is from Green Lane I
just thought I'd show you the existing
facilities so this is coming into where
this is just at the end of R par close I
thought i' show you the existing play
facilities on site so this is an
existing Council car par which could be
used uh for drop off at school Etc but
as you can see it looks like it's
already Fair capacity even when school's
not
on and from that car park the uh the
existing play facility is uh visible
there looks like quite a nice uh play
facility for the size of the village I
must
say this is the Landscaping plan so it's
quite a nice clear plan shows the
highway through the site um all the
Green Space within the site The Village
parking uh you can see up there along
with the school uh mini bus and coach
uh
spaces uh this is some of the elevations
so there's a large variety of designs on
site from um Terraces to Bungalows so
this is one of the terrist uh
blocks this is one of the
Bungalows and I'll just run through all
of the elevations uh
now
so as you can see there's uh a lot of
variety to the uh the designs that are
being proposed these are block of
flats and these are some Street Scene uh
elevations this is the drainage plan so
uh drainage will be um foul sewage will
be Tak
um to the public sewer and surface water
will be discharged into an attenuation
Pond which will then um come out into a
water course and attenuated
rate this is the highways plan so I mean
you've probably seen uh this or gauge to
this from the landscaping and site plan
but um shows quite clearly the Pavements
the road the foot paath running through
the
site this is a plan showing
visibility
so and you can see the road at 5.5
MERS visibility in that direction is 48
M and visibility in that direction is
51 the main plan considerations are as
follows and my recommendation uh is to
approve subject to conditions and 106 um
I pass back to um U chairman to
introduce the speakers thank you very
much thank you Christian thanks for that
presentation right who would like to
start the discussion on this
please you got the public speakers first
oh I beg you pardon yeah thank you thank
you Council L
yes uh right right well we have the
first speaker is Jillian underill if
she's here to speak on behalf of the
parish council Sean Sean you've got your
hand up to
speak I just checking that Julian
Underhill was in place counc I believe
she is in the meeting she
is okay thank you Jillian underill if
you would like to speak you'd have three
minutes to give your presentation on
behalf of the parish council
chair she needs to unmute muted
you hello hello we can hear you thank
you good morning everyone good morning
concerning the new planning proposal put
forward by Mr Rogers several important
concerns were brought to the council the
new entrance through Stony way which is
thought to be extremely unsafe and
unworkable even though highways believe
it to be visibility will always be poor
even though the problem appears to have
been resolved parking for present
residents School traffic and visitors
will be a nightmare as Beford will be
trying to cope with a large increase of
vehicles there are eight parking spaces
proposed for the village parking but
further into the report it states these
parking spaces will perhaps be under
ship and management of the primary
school so again we ask where do the
elderly and disabled residents living
directly opposite the proposed Junction
Park where do the people currently
living along the extremely busy
carriageway Park the village is
regularly blocked with heavy Goods
Vehicles this access will be used by
drivers as a pass passing area is this
safe for pedestrians of any age with no
existing footpath on this stretch of the
road but highway state it offers a safe
and suitable access we ask in what sense
is this suitable and safe Chapman's
entrance which was passed in
2011 at the west of the village would
alleviate beeford from most of the extra
traffic caused during building and upon
compl excuse me and upon completion
density has increased from the torage
recommendation um torage plan
recommendation by 30 % over a year
Beford is a small rural Village so this
major development could be detrimental
to an historical agricultural
environmental village with minimum
infrastructure it is accepted the S is
within the torage plan it's the
increased and overbearing size that's
the overarching
concern it has also been highlighted
that the Bungalows along exit the road
are to have houses built at the rear of
their properties could not Bungalows be
built to back onto these existing
Bungalows even though guidance boundary
measurements have been followed fears of
losing privacy and natural light are of
great concerns to these long-term owned
properties it is felt the new builds
finished in clading are not in keeping
with a rural Village should not a finish
be character with the area in which the
development is taking place as stated in
the hedner report
residents living in Marshall's me and Ry
Park are concerned over extra traffic on
the planning application a Ballard is to
be erected at the end of the new estate
blocking off the existing Marshall's me
Jillian could I ask you to wind up
please yes I've got one sentence left is
it a legality for an estate to have two
entrances if an emergency entrance is
needed again this raises the point that
the Stony way entrance in the middle of
the village on a busy road Ro pavement
no zebra Crossing is not appropriate
thank you very much committee for
listening thank you thank you for
that now we've got two speakers to speak
against this and the first one if he's
here is Peter Miller to speak against
are you there Peter
Miller on on mute if you are there
please you need to unmute
Peter yeah oh that's can you hear me now
I can hear you now Peter yes thank you
thank you you've got three minutes from
now please to give your presentation yes
thank you very much um first of all
there's been a lot of toing and throwing
correspondence on this i' just like to
say that the planning and highways
officers have been throughout most
polite and prompt in their response um
and that has contributed greatly to
enabling us to make uh the
representations we have made it's much
appreciated um I'm going to read now so
forgive me for that um policy bao2
states that the site should house
approximately 30 dwellings while this is
clearly not an absolute the proposal for
40 dwellings represents a 30% uplift
made only months after publication of a
democratically prepared local plan
approved by the
minister bao2 specifically states that
it should be to reflect local need but
with not a single job available in the
village and unsold properties on the
market I struggle to recognize such a
need local residents are generally happy
to accept the development of the land in
accordance with the local plan policy
arrived at by years of consultation and
compromise they do however object to the
policies being Trashed by a planning
officer who rather thinks he knows
better his reference to the 30 houses as
a minimum which appears uh about a page
after this um appears to endorse his own
view rather than anything stated in the
local plan and it actually might just as
well be taken as being a maximum figure
of 30 houses most importantly the access
is entirely
unsatisfactory when school children are
involved there is an imperative for
absolute safety and the lack of pavement
on the school side means that children
must cross the a road to reach such
safety uh the sight lines have been
fudged with a proposed traffic Peninsula
to the west to force Vehicles into view
and you'll see that from the plan that
was exhibited uh a few minutes ago sir
the net effect of this will be to
sterilize most of the on street parking
between Green Lane and the garage that
opposite the junction will go as a
result of traffic law and the proposed
new Peninsula at bird song will
sterilize all but a couple of spaces at
the Green Lane end removal of this this
facility will be devastating to
frontagers with no on-site parking
estimated to be a minimum of six
households so I emphasize that six
households are going to lose their
outside parking I shall add that I'm not
one of them their immunity will be comp
romis to the extent that their dwellings
are likely to suffer very significant
loss of value when challenged the
highways officer suggested that they
cross the road and use the new spaces
allocated adjoining the school and which
I think uh will be used Every Morning by
mothers dropping off children I urge
refusal of this ill-considered and
greedy application or at the very least
the deferral of a decision pending
solution of the density traffic and
parking issues thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr
Miller we have a
second public speaker against which is
Dennis buswell if he's here uh to speak
against if Dennis buswell's here could
you please unmute your
microphone and give us your presentation
please Dennis you're on iPhone I see if
you could unmute
your and then you're ail to speak oh if
we can I don't if we can unmute
you hello hello hello is that Dennis yes
it is but I have asked I have asked for
a letter to be read out because I've
just come out of Hospital oh all right
Mr bus well thanks for that I'll ask our
uh planning manager Sean Harrington to
read that letter then please W thank you
very
much uh thank you Mr buzwell thank you
councelor L um I do have Mr buell's
letter in front of me which I'll read
out
now now we have come to the committee
stage for discussion I would like to
highlight my main reason why this
application should not be granted
Planning Commission in its proposed
format I have raised my concerns from
experience as a project manager prior to
retirement I have asked previously for
answers to my question in my letters to
TTC planning
department counselors and MPS only once
have I had a response only one MP tried
to obtain answers for me this
application is one of two sites
identified suitable for development in
Beford
Village local plan identified in the
policy bea1 and Bea 02 was fully adopted
in October 2018 to cover the period from
2011 to
2031 this local plan took several years
in the making after consultations from
many groups of people at the large cost
of public money and a democratic
agreement was reached and the policy
bea1 and
bea2 was formed for approximately 42
dwellings shared between the two
sites while this agreement was pending
the same developer obtained planning
permission for nine dwellings on a site
outside of the boundary of the proposed
local plan this site allocation was for
approximately 30 dwellings and access
bya Beford garage site the development
principles included to provide vehicle
access access to the Village School with
parking facilities this will give relief
to traffic congestion in green Lan which
is a DDC HW says in a report is a very
poor substandard
Junction this application has ignored
its policy with its application for 40
dwellings and with a second best
proposed substandard Access Road
creating another substandard Junction on
the a31
124 how can taus District Council
planning department justify spending so
much time and money on such a flaw
application offering a 30% increase in
dwellings overly agreed policy on one
site and clearly clearly ignoring the
agreed adopted
policy the applicant should be asked to
go away and resubmit with proposals more
in keeping the local plan agreed with
which was agreed only two years
ago another consideration must be taken
into account and that is policy st7
special development strategy for northg
rural area I.E Villages development is
supporting the countryside
limit limiting it to that which is
enabled to meet local economic and
social
needs this Village has currently got a
site with nine dwellings under
construction three detached dwellings
next to the village hall with line
planning one conversion Barn one
detached dwelling near completion and 14
proposed on Bea 01 site and currently
seven houses on the for sale Market can
anyone explain what is the economic and
social needs are to justify more
dwellings in a small village
which is being proposed is a 50%
increase on housing stock of the village
this density of dwelling will have a big
adverse impact on the village in such a
short space of time remembering the
policy is from 2011 to
2031 we in Beford have a very good
Community spirit and enjoy a well-used
small Pub and Great Village Hall a
garage of a small shop all well
supported and with full employment
there's no further employment available
in the village the proposed development
is not about economics and social needs
it's about
profit there are approximately 75% of
Village People against this application
as it is currently presented with
sincere concerns for their way of
village life being taken away being away
from the hustle and stress of town life
is something worth holding on to what is
being proposed as a threat to that and
most importantly the safety of their
children and families is a serious
concern to create a new substandard
Junction opposite and near two
recognized inadequate Junctions and with
school access by children cross ing over
a busy aoad onto the junction with
little to no path is madness and a
serious accident waiting to happen I
hope the committee see a democratic Way
Forward you're sincerely de as
well thank you Sean for that and thank
you uh Mr buswell for sending that one
in right we've two speakers in support
of it now and the first speaker is John
blay who is the agent so Mr blay if
you're there you'll have three minutes
to speak in support of the
application Council L I've also got Mr
Blain's u letter and I don't believe he
is here so if I may I'll read that one
out as well thank you
Sean my name is John blay and my company
is the applicant's agent the application
is for 40 dwellings and Associated works
the history is that the site was
approved by the council schav panel
subsequently by a planning inspector and
is now included in the local development
plan a pre-plan planning application
inquiry was made followed by a public
participation process which was very
largely favorable to the
development extensive design and
Technical reports were then prepared and
commissioned culminating in a full
planning application lodged in May
2019 this has proved to be another very
expensive site to develop so subject to
approval today we are only able to offer
either section one or six contributions
as listed in our financial viability
assessment agreed with a district valuer
or the provision of four affordable
homes we have tried to accommodate the
local objectives where possible
particularly regarding the access which
will become the best designed and safest
in the village all the experts reports
are acceptable and there is Officer
support for the whole scheme the council
is short on delivery we are now able to
deliver the houses required subject only
to committee
approval clients are long-standing
reputable builders in the village
looking for continuity of supply for the
local
Workforce I respectfully request that
this site is approved subject to a
section 106 agreement John
blay thank you Sean for that and our
final speaker in support of this
application is Kelly Rogers if if she's
I don't if it's here or she if Kelly
Rogers is here please
hello hello can you hear me yeah we can
hear you thank you if you'd like to give
give us your uh presentation please
you'd have three minutes thank you hi
everyone good morning um I'm Kelly
Rogers wife of Dan Rogers and
daughter-in-law of Chris Rogers both are
local Builders the Rogers family has
lived in and been involved in building
houses in the village for nearly 40
years we're a small family business who
employ and Source materials locally and
would like to continue to grow our
business locally we are Keen to be the
ones that continue with the designated
development in the zone sites in Beford
we believe that most of the village
would prefer to have a local company
involved in its development Vel mment
rather than a large impersonal
construction company as a family we love
where we live and we're fully involved
in Village Life Dan and I married in
Beford church we have three children
that go to the school here I'm Secretary
of the school ptfa and Dan is a parish
counselor Chris was also a parish on the
Paris Council for several years in the
past with such a strong personal
connection to the Village we are hugely
sensitive to its needs we have ensured
the ri Park development is spacious
having a low density design with 10
units to the acre it is well planned and
provides houses suitable for a range of
buyers it has a new Village Green which
provides a safe area for children to
play and a 12 meter wide conservation
strip the length of the development
providing a diverse habitat for wildlife
the design of the ripart development has
also carefully considered the needs of
the school and the safety of the
children the plans include parking Bays
for the minib bus and coaches and and a
turning area for these vehicles the
entrance into the development is also
extremely safe in meeting the highways
requirements it is considered the safest
Junction in the whole village the plans
also include Pavements throughout
providing over 80 homes with a much
needed safe walking route to the school
we will be gifting the mini buus and
coach parking spaces to the school we
are currently halfway through a 9unit
development in the village at Marshall's
me through this development over £12,000
has been given to the parish council for
the existing Village Green and play area
this development is in keeping with our
ethos it is well-designed spacious and
provides well-built homes for a range of
buyers it includes four affordable homes
which were completed several months ago
and which have enabled young buyers to
purchase their first homes and remain in
the village all four units sold within
weeks of being on the market we're
extremely proud to have been able to
provide this opportunity and there are
plans for for another four affordable
homes in the Ry Park development we have
received a huge amount of interest and
supports from people in the village both
verbally and written following our
initial open plan meeting all we need
now is your approval which we would
greatly receive thank you very much for
your
time thank you very much Kelly Rogers
for for that presentation that is the
end of the public speaking for this
application so it's now open to the
committee to discuss and councelor lock
your first to speak on it
please yeah I think I ought to go first
because I said earlier it is in my world
um I think we all know that decisions
must be made in accord to the
development plan unless material
considerations indicate otherwise you
cannot um determine a decision on how
many supporters or objectives that you
have but I would just like to draw your
attention to the fact that one objector
in his letter stated that 75% of the
village are against it well there are
368 people on the Electoral run so 75%
equates to 276 objectives and on the
plan and P there are objections from 21
addresses fair enough there are multiple
um objections from those addresses but
only 21 addresses and as we know a
petition only counts for one um but I
just like to draw your attention to One
n of support which comes from the
school the safety of Children is
currently of concern due to a lack of
parking and no pavement along part of
Green Lane the plan includes access to
the school for the new development and
additional parking and this will help
relieve congestion on Green Lane which
is currently used as drop off and pickup
time the school and the nursery
currently have capacity for additional
pupils and the new housing will attract
families to the Village which will help
keep the school thriving and viable the
school recognized that affordable
housing for local people is very
important the rain in types of housing
will provide flexible housing
opportunities for local
people so I know that the main one of
the main objections and concerns of the
parish is the highways so I just wonder
if we can ask Mike nuk to come in at
this stage to explain why he thinks that
it is a safe access
please yes thanks Council L if um Mike
Nukem would like to comment on that
because uh Mr Miller one of the speakers
and i' I've made a note of it did
mention the peninsula on the highway now
I'm not sure what this peninsula is
that's on the highway is it a refuge or
what is this peninsula but Mike if if
you'd like to comment please thank you
chair yes you're you're quite right um
so effectively uh if I could just give a
quick rundown and I'll come to the point
you've made um it's a new access on to
the a 3124 the accesses itself where it
meets the highway is 5.5 m wide with
foot path uh 2 m footpath on um one
side um there to achieve visibility
they're narrowing the the actual a 3124
carriageway to 5.5 meters to extend
their
visibility they can achieve visibility
to the right because they have um um
entered into a legal agreement with the
adjacent land owners so they can get
visibility to the right visibility to
the left um they're putting in traffic
or chicane if you like which is not
dissimilar to the ones on the winkly
side which are existing at the moment so
effectively what that's going to do is
keep traffic on one side of the road um
and and like I said you know it already
fits into the existing which is there at
the
moment um the yeah not sure what else
and like I said the the um Junction has
got six meter radius uh around them so
that's effectively how they're being
able to uh achieve the visibility if I
just go on slightly more obviously the
test of this is that um access has to be
safe and suitable um so if I just
explain where I am with it at the moment
I've spoken to the um the engineer who
designed the scheme who is a Highway
engineer uh and and we discussed it
reasonable length he's obviously run
that past his colleagues who are also
Highway
Engineers as part of the process um it's
been subject to an independent safety
audit that hasn't raised any issues
not withstanding my own um thoughts on
the subject I've also run this past my
colleague they've raised no issues I've
run it past their own in-house Engineers
they've raised no issues and I've run it
past our own own in-house safety aitor
he's raised no issues now of course if I
was going to recommend refusal I would
have to do that with robust reasons of
why um on the possibility probability
likelihood whatever of it going to
appear when us having to defend it and
as it stands bearing in mind everything
I've said um about the the people who've
previously looked at it as well as my
own thoughts I think i' struggle to um
I'd struggle to recommend refusal and
defend this
appeal can I just ask um to come back
then about the loss of parking on the
highway because I I assume that people
do not have a right to park on the
highway in any case do they no you're
you're right sorry um and um like I said
as a highway Authority we've always
maintained that there is no right to
park on the public highway I don't think
the the highway Authority's ever been
successful challenged on that um now the
the applicant hasn't actually included
any park restrictions per se in so far
as yellow lines clear away that requires
a legal order however of course with any
access or or feature um Highway law has
to be um um obeyed and followed and it's
always you know people are are well
advised to follow the highway code as
well so therefore people can't obstruct
as a result of that because of the
traffic Karma that they're proposing and
because of the actual juncture I think
the highway code says you can't park
opposite or within 10 meters of a
juncture there will be lots of
parking um Mike have you have you
assessed how many I know there's no well
there there's no legal right to park on
the highway but it's not illegal to park
on the highway either have you assessed
how many parking spaces will be lost
because looking at this application in
detail I notice opposite the proposed
Junction obvious they'll lose parking
correct there are eight on site uh
parking spaces proposed but this
peninsula this chicane yes to the left
further down the road towards more
towards the center of the village really
yes that will obviously affect a certain
amount of parking along the road there
correct now F enough I was just going to
come on to that so so effectively we're
looking at um um what the mitigation is
um I would say this point I think the
lady from the parish council pointed out
the fact that about the um the eight
parking space and I believe that they
shouldn't just be used for the my
understanding was they're not just for
the school they're also for um The Wider
um wider residents as well so you're
quite right opposite the junction will
lose so the easiest way of looking at it
is for example over those eight parking
spaces when you look at parallel parking
spaces on the highway we allow about six
meters I think the average length of a
car is four and a half meters um that's
average length um we allow for six
meters so so let's go with that six
meter um um figure and there's eight
parking spaces so effectively what
they've done is mitigated for 48 meters
worth of um of uh loss of parking if
that makes sense um
so and on top of that as well I would
also add that the intention for the
estate is to be adopted as public
highway so that in itself will also
create parking opportunities for people
to park on uh in the future just like
they can park on a 3124 now because it
is public Highway um so uh like I said
all all that all that together I do
believe like I said there is reasonable
mitigation okay Mike thank you councelor
lock you anything can I just make one
other um point before I listen to what
other Council have got to say um
affordable housing is always an
issue as we all know that all the um
developers always go to the district Val
and they came they come back to say
whether it's okay or not and I um I
noticed that the DB agrees that um no
affordable housing could be obtained if
they have to pay all the 106 agreements
I quite like his idea and I think Rachel
agree with it that should the
application be
granted um and people want to stick with
the 106 contributions but that viability
study is visited at regular intervals to
see if it changes because we're in very
difficult times at the moment but um I
do thank the officer Chris for coming
back to myself and the chair of the
parish council with this idea that if um
the section 106 monies are not payable
then they will be able to do for foral
houses which I think is the best way
forward because with the regard to the
106 monies I mean particularly with Dem
County Education we always have this I
mean they are asking for I mean we're
talking about 5. five
pupils um and they are looking for
£15,000 and then what really um goes
against the grain
4474 transport for five years I mean in
my opinion that a ridiculous amount for
five pupils it's not to say that five
pupils go to torington school some might
choose to go to CH so I think again if
this is granted and we can disperse with
the
106 and get four affordable hous it will
be a plus to the Village so I will stop
there and listen to what others have got
to say before I come back again thank
you thank you councelor lot well I'll
just pick up on on the point because I
made a note of it last night when I was
looking finalizing this application my
views on it a verbal update on
affordable to buy is what was mentioned
and Christian mentioned this at the
start that they've agreed that they will
provide
for affordable to buy not affordable
houses to rent as I heard it uh open
market at a discounted rate now is that
what's being proposed or is it going to
be affordable houses to
rent perhaps um and I'll bring Chris
Chris eely and the planning officer to
answer
that Chris you're
muted classic okay sorry um so yeah that
would be affordable to buy rather than
um affordable to rent I understand the
um agent did actually explore with a
number of housing associations however
um none were willing to take up uh
Beford as a as an option so even if we
had more affordable housing on site it's
likely that it would be difficult to get
a provider actually in there have we any
idea what this discounted rate will be
because the government in the white
paper talking about
30% discounted on housing I know it's a
discussion document that but what kind
of a discounted rate on these four are
being
offered um so it's between so normally
they would sell for between 70 to 80% of
market value depending on the site so
we'd have to look at that uh in further
detail in the section 106 um but yeah it
there would be approximately 20 to 30%
off of the final value usually
and this in no way affects the uh 106
payments which amount Council lot
mentioned it I got a figure here £
254,000 in total so it's not going to
affect that at all there will be paid as
well and the discounted rate of four of
the dwellings no so you would either
have um you'd either have the discounted
rate affordable housing and none of the
offsite contributions or you'd have the
offsite
contributions and none of the affordable
housing that is that is essentially the
option uh unfortunately due to viability
they cannot provide any any more than
that um so that's
um speaking to um Council lock um
understand the preference is is likely
to be more on the side of the affordable
housing um but at the end of the day
that will be um you know a discussion
for you guys and ultimately um um as
members and ultimately thank thanks
Chris it's not as I understood it then I
thought there's going to be you know a
discount on for dwellings to be sold as
affordable uh not affordable as we know
it for rent but but for sale anyway I'll
bring some of the other members in can I
just come back on that a minute Chris
please yeah go on and then councelor
mcg's next to speak cancel lot yeah on
an earlier sorry the phone's on an
earlier application developers they had
affordable to buy and recollection I
think they were sold at a 68% 68% of the
market
value and um on that development Rachel
webale fully supported that so I think
that's the best way forward right okay
thanks K A Lot C Chris you've got your
hand up again before I bring in
councelor
mcof you're muted again you're
muted the um the agent did confirm sorry
that the uh it would be a similar scheme
to the previous one on site so uh which
is uh let me show you so this was uh
nine plots with plan permission and they
provided four affordables on that um in
2014 so um if that's got 68 then I think
we could probably push for that because
the agent has claimed that it would be a
scheme to that so in terms of How It's
managed and
sold thank you councelor mcgoff you've
been
patient thank you very much Mr chairman
I'd like to move straight
into proposing that we Grant this
application subject to no off-site
contributions because I'm very keen on
seeing some affordable development for
the village and actually giving locals a
chance to actually buy a house and
actually stay in the village which is
actually key to me um I'd also like to
touch on the the highways I think
highways absolutely spot on what they've
done the developers work very closely
with the highways and relevant parties
I'm happy to see the access to the
school and the allocated spaces of
parking which also all the safety for
the primary school itself so my proposal
is that we Grant this application
subject to no off-site contributions
therefore maximizing the affordability
of the site thank you thank you
councelor Watson you're next to speak
please yeah thank you chair uh I haven't
got much to say now D not said it all uh
if he's proposing it I I'm going to
seconded it because I totally agree with
him thank
you can I just uh councelor Christie
like to speak now please hello counselor
Christie to speak please I haven't
finished I thought you had you stopped
speaking coun Watson carry on then you
you SED I thought you finished no no I I
I was I was one of the people that that
committee members that approved the
other one and and I think it it's a
really good idea to put four affordable
outters there they have the parking like
Derm says and and and what Rose is
saying and yes well you know that I'm
going to Second it anyway okay thank you
I'll finish now chair thank you are you
sure councelor Chris councelor Christie
had his hand up to speak thank you well
I was going to Second it as well um can
I ask one thing because uh you know that
I always raise this issue about um
affordable
houses uh on other sites we've seen you
know very steep hills theyve got
drainage problems yet this is a flat
agricultural field where I cannot see
any physical problems at all so I was a
bit
surprised um that we weren't going for
our 30% affordable I understand no
Housing Association wants to take it on
but did I just hear just now that you
said the early development where the
nine plots they provided four affordable
that's four out of nine and yet on this
site which is 40 houses there's only
going to be four can I ask what that uh
number will go up to if we don't take
any uh section 10 Sixers does anyone
know well as Chris Chris eily said it's
either or it's either these four
discounted dwellings and we don't know
exactly what the discount will be or
it's the 106 contributions of 254,000
it's one of the
other am I right CH yeah come on okay
yeah so that's that's correct chair I'm
sorry um councelor chrisy I'm not
entirely certain that I UND understood
your question to be honest
um but I I kind of get what you're
saying that why proportionately 4 to9
and 4 to 40 is much different I I don't
know the specifics of the 2014
application but it uh obviously is an
unallocated site Etc this application
itself has been assessed independently
and then uh so they've they've provided
their own assessment we've then got gone
out and got our own viability assessment
from the district valer and then that's
also being independently assessed by uh
our in-house um s Ral so I can say um
categorically that this uh site isn't
technically viable um to meet with um
policy
st8 um but polic S185 does state that
negotiations F the scale and nature of
affordable housing provision along with
the balance of other infrastructure and
planning requirements will be considered
on the basis of a robust appraisal of
development viability so would say that
the proposal isn't actually contrary to
policy because we have gone through a
what I would say a robust um appraisal
of the development
viability um each site is different that
and housing values Etc on every
different site will uh change the
ultimate profit which the uh which the
developer can take we don't know uh for
obvious reasons due to co Etc what the
actual state of play is um it could be
that in the southwest for example house
prices rise significantly but it could
be that they plummet we we simply don't
know so I would recommend that uh within
this uh section 106 as well as the uh if
you're proposing the forward to take
them but I would recommend that we do um
have this updated uh process where at a
later stage if it's uh turns out to be
more viable then we can potentially take
more affordable dwellings hopefully
that's answered your question if it
hasn't um let me know um what you want
uh to know and I'll try and answer it
cheers thank you Chris can I just come
back on that because uh this site is in
our local plan and again it
highlights uh what I think is a lack of
Forward Thinking and that we've
allocated this site and yet clearly
under our under these valuation things
it doesn't actually sit with our attempt
to get 30% affordable um and we see this
on every site it seems we've got another
one coming out later this morning um I
think we if we get any applications in
now the speculative ones because of our
lack of fiveyear PL uh land Supply that
we actually look at these sites very
very
carefully before we allow them because
I'm just getting more and more
frustrated that we are not not getting
more of these affordable houses Beford
is a lucky Village it's got a school
it's got a pub not many villages have
both now uh we need young people in our
Villages and the more affordable houses
the better it is for the village uh
rather than have more and more elderly
retirees coming down um and I I really
do get frustrated over this and I still
cannot understand how a development of
nine houses can afford to sell four of
them affordable and yet a development of
40 houses is only offering four I take
on what on board what Chris has said
that we can uh return to this a bit
later but I still do not understand how
those ratios are so different
sorry thank you councelor Christie
councelor craigy is next to speak can I
answer those questions share quickly
sorry to pop in um yes sorry councelor
Christie yeah I umum I think you know
everyone shares uh the frustration that
we can't deliver 30% but um as as I
previously said it it has been uh
assessed um as we have to look at this
site we cannot really compare it to
other sites each site is assessed on its
own individual merits so whilst I I do
understand the site is next door Etc
same developer it's a different uh it's
not allocated it's a different point in
time Etc so I will say just to review
this site rather than uh apprising the
other site there is a decent range of
homes on the site in terms of uh smaller
units Bungalows Terrace houses Etc so in
terms of actually providing houses which
might also be affordable even though
they're not technically affordable the
site might also do a fairly good job of
doing that in the form of teres Etc so
um hopefully that overcomes your concern
but I simply can't answer what the
difference is and I don't think it NE
necessarily be appropriate to because we
should just focus on this site and its
IND individual merits thanks thank you
Chris can I bring in councelor craigy
now please thank you um can you hear me
all right yes yeah yeah good um I think
it's an overdevelopment and it it um it
causes me concern that we've let 30
houses turn into 40 houses because that
is a considerable increase it's a small
village I I have driven through it quite
a lot and I know that it's all the
traffic is always difficult going
through the village because of the
parking so I think um there needs to be
more parking spaces um of course this is
going to cause more traffic coming in
and out and I I want it to be in keeping
with the village I think so important to
maintain the character of villages and I
think this is more like a Suburban
development like we getting bord it's a
bit squashed in I I like the fact we've
got a few
Bungalows but I and I I do think we need
the affordable homes I agree with what
everybody said that affordable homes are
essential but on the other hand if the
school is already at CAPA capacity and
the the county has no money um we have
to get the section 106 money to pay for
the school so I think this is terrible
dilemma that it puts us all into not
knowing which way to go um I I think the
important thing is that the people who
live in the village should be able to
buy the houses and should be able to
continue to live there um and so I I'm
totally split really on what we should
do about the section 106 but really I
can't see why we have let if we let
every development increase by
30% it's an enormous amount and it and
it I think it's you know something that
I don't see how it's got past us so so
easily without us taking note of
it thank you councelor craigy councelor
brown thank thank you chair um yeah
listened to what everybody else has said
and it does make sense to me that um I I
just can't understand how a flat piece
of
land can commer so many um expenses and
we have to um lose on a affordable
houses it seems to me that we need
affordable hous in I'd like to know how
many we've actually built over the last
year when there is sort of demand for
them chair so can the officer give us
any idea of how many affordable houses
have actually been built in torage
because we seem to be getting less and
less thank you
chair I don't we'll be able to get that
information just off bat like that
councelor brown because uh these a bit
of research I think to see exactly
what's been uh approved and what's been
actually provided but I know it won't be
very much I realize that um so chair can
I just say as as well that I do agree
with um you know that the fact that the
contributions are very high and I
wouldn't want to exchange them in favor
of affordable housing it's a very
difficult dilemma as councelor Craig has
said Thank You chair thank you councelor
brown um Sean can you come in now see
you've got your hand up and then Chris e
wants to come in again
Sean uh thank you Council L um I thought
I'd just uh come in and discuss some of
the matters that Council Christie and
Council Brown quite rightly brought up
this is very important for um committee
members discussion for this application
and I'm sure the planning officer would
have brought these up anyway moving
forward um differences between the two
uh sites the previous 2014 site and this
site obviously we are um six years
further forward now um in relation to
the viability of this site it's worth
noting from Le District value's
viability report and that's some
abnormal costs associated with this site
as opposed to the other site uh mainly
being off-site surface water drainage um
District value looked at that as being
£60,000
but also Le cost ofly access Ransom um
so this is the purchase of the Bungalow
and the demolition of the Bungalow the
site wouldn't have had that we've also
got cost of Highway works and also
remembering that this site is providing
a car park for the school um fully drop
off the school buses and also Village
car park and there's quite a large
landscape area um to the south of the
site as you look at the plan on the
screens at the moment with 10 meters um
which you wouldn't necessarily see in an
application but that was part of the
actual allocation um so all these
figures together plus the cost of
building that has gone up since 2014
whilst the value of the properties of
plateaued result in the development
coming through reliability assessment as
you've seen it um and as the district
value has agreed um only been able to
provide a certain amount of affordable
dwellings although I am very keen that
we look at um putting a review mechanism
in any section 106 that's agreed um
certainly given the times that we have
at the moment in relation to the density
on the site um it's been raised by both
the planing officer and members of the
public that the allocation is an
approximate figure and it is an
approximate figure um although obviously
nine it's nine additional dwelling so
we're actually providing 39 taking into
account demolition is quite an increase
however if I draw members attention to
the officers report and the planning
balance um so 9.2 and 9.3 of the officer
report just highlighting that we are in
a position where we have a lack of 5,9
Supply so the Tilted balance um is
engaged um as we know we have got an
issue of housing Supply in the wi tus
District the planning officer is content
the design and layout and the density
put forward on this site and this isly
for members to look at but looking at
the plan that's think that I also agree
with and whil is higher than the
approximate figure in the um allocation
policy uh given the Tilted balance and
the design site something that your
officers are content with um and
obviously that's something that you may
want to discuss further thank you
thank you Sean uh oh Chris has put his
hand down again councel
lock yeah I just like to come back on
something that counc prey said um she
said that the scores um full to capacity
well the school is not full to capacity
they've um stated in their letter of
support that they have spaces to both
the school and the nursery so that was
one point and just going back to be I
mean it is a thriving Village they've
got someone just said an excellent
school nursery theyve got a local pub
they've got a garage they've got a small
shop they've got a village hall they've
got a church they've got a chapel
they've got very well equipped um play
area um and they've got a cricket long
established Cricket pitch and the
cricket team so they are a thriving
Village and I do think it's important
that um this application goes through um
and can I just confirm that when counil
the go propos and Council Watson
seconded that you um your proposal does
contain um to do the four affordable
houses and no offsite or Devon education
contributions at all could you confirm
that please I can confirm that for me R
Deo I free to chair can I speak yeah g
coun yeah no orig what I said was was a
proposing the gr application with no
offsite
contributions which obviously then the
stress on the importance of the
affordable has been available forly
hopefully locals of the village you know
this is this parent we get this
affordability through for the public not
the offsite contributions because I just
think they're what p in the sky
figures can I just clarify it's not that
we're we're against all offsite
contributions because I mean the
highways and all the rest of it's got to
be done that that all that kind of thing
we're talking about the education
contributions principally aren't we
that's what we're talking
about which is which is which is 100 odd
th000 uh
115,000 and then another 40 odd, 44,000
for transport they're what we're talking
about not not the rest of the offsite
yeah that this will pay for
I think there's also about 70,000 in for
the for the Cricket Club and and and
money for the play area as well I
noticed reading
through so so that's sorry I had my hand
up but didn't want to barge in um yeah
so that is correct so it's the off-site
contributions towards um Sports play and
education um that we would be uh seeking
to exchange in uh for the affordable
housing that's fine that's okay by me
right
well it's really money the waters for me
this has because the four the four
dwellings being offered at a discounted
rate we've no idea what that discounted
rate is we no idea what the difference
would be whether it's 30,000 a dwelling
or what it is but all these other
offsite contributions have gone by the
board if if this is supported and I'm I
don't feel very happy with that that we
we're not talking about affordable
housing as we know it we're talking
about for discounted open market
dwellings and without knowing what these
dwellings will be selling for although
there's an idea in the uh viability
appraisal of what the light and the
market is an all-time high at present
the housing market is um I'm a bit
concerned about the loss of all this
offsite contribution Sean
Harrington thank you counc L just to
confirm that the housing at the um
reduced cost will be classed as
intermediate affordable housing U so
from a wider planning policy um
Viewpoint and National policy it is
classed as affordable housing and it
would fall within that bracket um in
relation to the value um a figure of 68%
uh was discussed and that's something
that we looked to push for and it could
be that if that wasn't achievable we
could come back uh to committee um but
i' uh hopefully uh we to see 68% as
being a figure that we look for on this
side thank you councelor
Craig thank you um I just wanted to ask
with respect to the affordable homes um
do local people get
priority um I wouldn't like to see these
uh discounted homes going to people
coming in from
outside
can you answer that Sean how will this
be conditioned if we accept this or
Chris you've put your hand up to speak
either one of you if you can answer that
please thank you chair so yeah it
usually goes uh in in sort of a trickle
so uh it would be uh members it would be
they would be advertised to members of
the parish and members uh if that's
unsuccessful uh members of The Wider
Ward Etc until a point that eventually
they say we what we couldn't do is
stagnate it uh in its entirety but yeah
so it's done for locals first and then
it goes out and then they remain the
same goes if they then come to sell them
at a future date so the same principles
apply can I come back on that yeah ccel
Craig what happens if a bu toet person
wants to buy them if if um nobody else
has purchased
them
somebody answer that question please
yeah I think I'll jump in there I'm not
quite sure I understand um what say the
affordable housing would have to stay as
an affordable house and dwelling and the
occupants have to meet that criteria um
so it wouldn't be a bu to that in the
open market um if that's the concern I'm
not quite sure I answer the question
counc GRE sorry
yeah I just wanted to make sure that um
people from outside couldn't come in and
buy it as an investment
opportunity uh no it' have to be within
the remit of the um intermediate F
housing as put in section
one6 thank
you councelor christe you had your hand
up
again oh I actually put my hand down
again because C craigy asked the very
question I was going to ask
okay thanks for that thank
you right
well uh I've got one question that's not
cropped which is the drop off point for
the school buses and the mini buses
parking there's three spaces there and
there's three for large coaches to park
um and then the access is through the
playing field is there a foot path or a
proper path across the playing field to
the school or are they walking through
wet grass to the
school
I couldn't see it looking through the
report or looking on all the plans I've
not seen what kind of a path is there
from from this proposed development to
the actual school and
Nursery thanks councilor l so yeah the
school would have to um reshuffle its
Arrangements uh essentially with uh in
leison with the developer I understand
they've already been in discussions um
but yeah so is currently a playing field
uh I can get the pictures up uh or to
some extent I
[Music]
can there is a small bit tarmac that
runs around you can see it
there
um to the right hand side but yeah they
they might have to they might have to
make their own arrangements with regards
to uh making the school suitable for
this rear drop off Arrangement however
we know the school is in support of the
scheme they're aware of this arrang
management they've written in in in
support of the new drop off facilities
Etc so I can't foresee it being uh a
problem that they're not going to work
out okay thank you Chris councelor
mcgoff yeah thank you much just trying
to alleviate some of your concerns over
the access to the school there um I
think you had a Mrs Rogers you spoke
earlier on the application as it you
know it's a local family developing this
been here for generations and
I think she had three uh three children
go to school as well so I'm pretty
certain she's kind of keen to get
children the school safely you know the
wellknown family working together with
local community I already see him trying
to upset local community so hope some
concerns
there thank you right well it's been
proposed and set it proposed by
councelor mcgoff secondly by councelor
Watson to Grant this
application um
can I can I get just some clarification
then on what's happening with these four
these four affordable to buy open
market at a discounted rate is that
going to be a 106 condition then for
that can Sean answer that please or
Chris yes sorry Council yes that have to
form part station 106 agreement okay
right um Sandra then it's been
recommended to approve can you go to the
vote please
yes chair thank you councelor bowon uh
for councelor brown
four councelor Christie for councelor
craigy
against councelor
leather
poor councelor lock po councelor
mcof four councelor Watson
four councelor wisan
or that's eight for and one against
chair thank you Sandra thanks for that
right we move on then to our next
application which
is
application 1 oblique
2009 an outline application this is um
at not
at Easter water in bidford and I think
Laura you're you're giving us a
presentation on this one
please thank you chair yeah can CH
before we go on can I just say I'm duel
hatted over this because this has
already come to bord Town Council yeah
thank you councelor
Christie thank you chair and the
application under consideration is made
in outline only with access being the
only detailed matter the applications
for residential development are up to 96
dwellings with Associated Highway Works
access and the provision of a car park
for users of the T Trail all matters of
layout scale appearance and Landscaping
remain reserved and are not for
consideration at this
stage the application site is located in
East the water and to the south of the B
oford bridge this site plan is not
particularly well orientated north south
and but for guidance the river torage is
to the top of the page within the T
trail running alongside the red
line between the river and and the
application site uh the application site
includes sort of a main main area of the
site and also the access running out to
torington Street which uh runs
underneath the Railway Bridge and then
uh then
stops the aerial photograph um maybe
shows us a little clear in terms of it
relationship to uh surrounding east of
water so we've got um access to the to
the north and with the Tet trail running
from the top of the page to the
bottom then we
have the so Tor Street runs from the
north down into the site um members be
familiar with this large deon's yard
area to the north of the site and a
western power um Depot as well the
application site then has the Tet Trail
which extends along the western
boundary um and then to the south of the
application site we have some
residential dwellings to
the uh Southwest Southeast Corner
apologies um and uh other industrial
uses to the southwestern corner there's
an existing access road that runs
through the site which would largely be
retained as part of the proposals um
providing access to the neighboring
sites so i' got some photographs is
taken from the southern boundary of the
site um and looks up along the existing
Access Road uh for reference the big
blue building you can see is the Jon's
um
site and then photographs taken again
from the southern boundary of site this
is looking towards neighboring dwellings
at
nutural and then turning around showing
the view to the existing industrial
units further south including jameston
engineering
this is a view um from the west side of
western boundary of the site looking
east across the center of the site as
members will recall from site visit it's
fairly overgrown site it's very
difficult to different decipher exactly
where the boundaries
are and we have a view from the western
boundary of the site looking along the
Tara trail to the South so shows the
relationship to the Tara Trail and also
again the overgrown nature of the
existing
site we have a view again from the
western boundary but this is time
looking up towards and the more recent
development in east of water which you
can see on the hill there to the
Northeast and a view more centrally in
the site again along the access road
looking North showing the relationship
to Jon's
building we have an overall illustrative
site plan as I say this is in outline
only so the part
the main part of the site is only
illustrative purposes to to demonstrate
that 96 dwellings could be accommodated
on the site um and then next slide sort
of break this plan down a little more so
the northern part of the site is the
area along torington Street and this
shows the proposed Highway
works so the proposal is for Works to be
undertaken from The Junction to the
south of the blacksmith's arms so to
then move the foot path predominantly
over to the western side of the highway
provide a consistent um Road width and
consistent um foot path width of of 1.8
MERS extending South all the way along
to existing links up onto the tarer
trail which are in place and
then the the road becomes a private
Highway after the bridge with the Tara
Trail so at this point
Point um and then running south from
there as a private road The Proposal is
to retain a 5.5 meter width
Road um so the footpath access onto the
Tet Trail is shown as existing but I
think we also had a discussion as part
of the site visit about um a proposed
additional pedestrian link up onto the
Tet Trail which was approved as part of
a 2017 application um for the
neighboring site at the tader um which
is shown there and we're providing
alternative pedestrian access up onto
the Tet
Trail uh so I've included just for for
completeness um details of that uh that
previous approved scheme for an
additional pedestrian access up onto the
Tet
Trail um the this is the tree
constraints plan that's been submitted
as part of the application um and just
for reference to members as part of the
ecology
um elements within the officers report
reference was made to an ash tree within
the center of the site which is shown
with the blue rings around it in the
center there but predominantly the main
trees on the site are on the eastern and
western
boundaries um with I think the
arboricultural report also points to the
number of self-seeded um and overgrown
stubs that have taken place on the site
by evolution of
time uh and then this is the
illustrative site plan which has been
submitted um say it's for indicative
purposes only just to demonstrate that
the Quantum of development sort could be
accommodated on the site um but it does
include um the proposed TKA Trail Car
Park uses of the T Trail to be included
as part of the application and to be
secured by the section 106 so you can
see it's sort of indicatively noted to
be um shown on the plan there um with
the existing access up onto the Tet
trail to the
the West to be
retained um these are the material
planning considerations have been set
out in the officer's report um just a
short summary in relation to
viability um the applicant provided a
viability assessment in relation to the
application and that included a number
of abnormal costs associated with the
site including Works to put overhead
cables underground and uh drainage Works
uh that concludes Ed that the proposed
development could not provide the
required amount of affordable housing
and planning obligations whilst
resulting in a profit for the
developer uh the council had this report
independently assessed by the district
valuer and they concluded in their
initial report that even a fully open
market scheme with the provision of the
section 106 contributions would not
result in a viable scheme at that time
the section 106 contributions were
actually indicated to be about £600,000
which is above what what was sought um
with the more recent consultation rounds
on this application but the district Val
in that initial report also went further
to confirm that although no affordable
housing can be provided on the site some
section 106 contributions could be
provided and they undertook some
viability T some sensitivity testing for
us and and indicate sort of a range that
that could be provided
with um the requested contributions
which have been sought for the scheme in
the most recent uh round of
consultations are a total of 300
8,38 but those are towards primary
education and then also a further
contribution towards Highway Works to
improve the junction of the a39 at
Wesley um both of these contributions
couldn't be achieved within the uh range
of contributions that the district value
were identifi was
feasible um subsequently discussions
were undertaken with the Strategic
enabling officer and the applicants in
relation to potentially providing some
affordable housing on site
um and an assessment of a reasonable
profit level for the developer taking
into account the risks associated with
the site and the need for an incentive
to bring the site forward that con
concluded with it being viable to
provide seven affordable dwellings on
the site but with no other section 106
contributions and the developer
accepting a lower profit
level um in relation to the section 106
um section of my report um which is
section 10
that does note that discussions have
been undertaken with local Ward members
in terms of the priorities for
infrastructure and Community benefits
from the development at the time that
the report was finalized discussions
have been undertaken with two of the
three Ward members and they both
emphasized the need for affordable
housing as a priority in East the water
um since finalizing the officers report
though we have had comments from the
Third Ward member um which um I read out
as follows they State I would rather see
no affordable housing if it meant the
local infrastructure could be improved
housing with no infrastructure uplift
isn't really viable I have asked for
some clarification as to exactly what
specific infrastructure the council
would like to see but I haven't had any
confirmation uh so on the basis of the
responses received at the time of the
report they reflect the opinions of two
of the three Ward counselors um and
officers therefore recommended the
provision of the seven affordable
dwellings with no other off-site
contributions being
made um the recommendation is for
approval subject to the various
conditions set out at the end of the
officers report and the section 106
agreement that seeks to secure um
on-site green infrastructure the
provision of the car park for users of
the Tet Trail and seven affordable
dwellings following the viability
assessments thank you
chair thank you Laura we've we've one
speaker listed for this and it's the
agent Mr John blay I don't know if he's
here for this one or
not uh no council l i I'll be reading Mr
Blay's letter all right thank you Sean
if you do that then okay uh my name is
John blay of John blay limited the
applicants agent the application is for
96 dwellings and Associated Works
including ATA Trail Car Park
improvements to tton Street additional
pedestrian access points to the Tara
Trail dm10 open space provision all with
no Financial
contributions this Brownfield site has a
long-standing commitment for residential
development is now included in the local
development plan as adopted by the
council extensive design and Technical
reports were prepared culminating in a
full planning application lodged in
March
2009 subsequently those reports have
been updated several times requested
additional reports added amended and now
finally all agreed with your
officers this has proved to be another
very expensive site to develop this is
reflected in agreed Financial viability
assessments by Group West and the
council's advisor the district
valer this means that subject to
approval today we are able to offer
either section 106 contributions as
listed in the group West Financial
viability assessment or the provision of
seven affordable homes all the experts
reports are accepted and there is
Officer support for the whole scheme the
council is short on delivery all housing
is desperately needed depending on your
depending upon your decision today we
wish to deliver these houses as soon as
practicable I respectfully request that
the site is approved by committee
subject to section 106 agreement without
any further delay John blay
thank you
Sean well that's the end of the speakers
for this application but what I would
say to start with is it is an outline
application so it's
establishing uh the principle of
development on this Brownfield site and
councelor Chris are you to speak first
please well thank you yes I did say um
on Dual hated this came before the bit
of the Town Council plans committee and
you'll see from our agenda that that
bord is actually opposed to this
development um it is the the last last
large area flat land left in bford but
you have to ask yourself why hasn't it
already been developed and there are
very reasons uh firstly
contamination um I'd like the way they
they talk about this is a Brownfield
site early industrial use the earlier
industrial use was actually in the first
world war it was a ammunitions Factory
producing
exposes uh so there is quite a lot of
contamination I suspect in World War II
the US Army uses as an ammunition dump
so it's got more contamination from that
um you'll see that there a very low
percentage of affordable being offered
and I suspect that uh the contamination
the cleanup is actually going to reduce
that even
further uh the problem that we really
targeted we really focused on was um
whichever way you enter the site the
access is absolutely
appalling you've heard uh earlier the
officer saying that that there's going
to be improvements but they're only from
the blacksmith arms down to this site uh
if you look at the original calling
which I see was
2009 uh the Council of then she put her
finger on it uh access along torington
Street anyone who has driven down tor
Street will realize just how narrow that
is the houses are right on the pavement
and it there's no way of improving it if
you go around nutberry uh around the
other way uh the corner there is
possibly the worst Corner in bord it's a
90 degree Bend uh it's so narrow it's
just incredible uh to talk about putting
96 new houses with all the traffic flows
that would engender coming down to
street it's just appalling um and this
is why the Town Council actually uh did
not support this um it is a shame if you
want to go back in history that uh the
Link Road when they put it came across
the high level Bridge it should have
gone the other way by this site it would
have been a much cheaper bridge and it
would have opened up this development
land But there again that's past history
um I did mentioned our earlier meeting I
was I
was astonished to find Devon County
asking for nearly 100,000 for
improvements to the Wesley Junction
which of course is in North Devon uh I
did ask how many sites in North Devon
had actually sent money to torage I
didn't get any answer to that uh I would
certainly not support any money going to
to that uh on balance I'm going to go
with the rest of my counselors on the
Town Council planning committee and
oppose them
uh we are just really creating massive
new problems along a street in bford
that already has huge problems thank
you thank you councelor Christie
councelor
craiger thank you chair I'd just like to
agree with everything counselor Christie
just said I mean um I know the site well
and although the actual site itself
would would be fine for development it
is the question of getting in and out of
the site it goes under a quite a small
Bridge um there's no pavement and
looking at the plans I don't see how
they can be much of a pavement if it's
all family homes they've all got to get
to the school um and they've got to get
in and out of the site I mean if if
anybody ever hit the
bridge um and it was an accident there
would be no access in and out to this
site at all
unless you went up the Tet Trail um I
just I can't see I think it needs to
have another access road if if there was
a way of getting another Access Road in
say from um you know from up the hill
maybe from Churchill where I live um
then it it possibly would be feasible
but the way the way the access is at the
moment I I can see it being a disaster I
mean especially as it's right near the
flood plane if all if all that track um
was flooded we couldn't get the people
in and out of there so they'd be
stranded in the houses up there
um it just doesn't
work that's thank you thank you thank
you councilor craigy
Sean thank you Council Le I was just
wondering if now would be a good
opportunity to bring the Devon County
highways officer in to comment um it's
clearly serious concerns about the
access in this application well yeah we
can do because I've got serious serious
issues with the access to this site I
really have um we've not had any
photographs Laura put up of the access
down toron street which I think we had
at the present the virtual presentation
was there some photographs of
it because I think everybody I don't
know about members from out in some of
the rural areas if they do know
torington street from the roundabout
about coming off the old bridge uh which
councelor Christ refer to down to the
blacksmith's arms it's a dreadful
stretch of road um but I've I've got
many questions on the access and also
footways to to do this um have we any
photographs Laura or not apologies chair
I I had a video obviously that we showed
at the uh the site visit but I don't
have any photographs can we show the
video at all are we able to show
that we we're looking into it chair bear
with me moment well maybe maybe the
members who were at the site visit do
remember that video then and exactly
what the approach is like from the
roundabout at the end of the old bridge
down Torrington street but yeah Sean
bring in the highway
officer
please yes good morning chairman members
um I mean I'd be happy to listen to
other members concerns before commenting
if you'd like or um yeah all right fine
y thank
you okay thanks Matt well I've got a
list here um there's no foot path on the
new Access Road that's proposed from the
bridge where it becomes a private
stretch of road there is no foot path
and yet in the transport assessment
that's been submitted on behalf of the
applicant it shows a three meter wide um
cycle footway all the way along that
road to the new what's happened to that
that's disappeared the the only access
apparently is up onto the Tet Trail
which isn't lit there's no Street
lighting along there but to put that
amount of traffic through torron street
is ridiculous and coming down nuttery
hill towards the the bridge the Old
Railway Bridge that is the Tet Trail
it's a dreadful Junction that turning
out from there into torington Street you
can't see anything to the right you just
take a chance and pull out there uh and
they're doing a way with the foot path
on that side so everybody coming down
nuttery hill on foot and a lot of people
do come down there on foot because
there's a lot of businesses in nutberry
there small businesses a lot of garages
a lot of garages and
um car repair businesses in there panel
panel repair companies so a lot of
people leave cars there and walk into
town from there uh and it's an awful
Junction you're going to have to cross
that there we are we've got the video
this is a first part of Torrington
Street going down
you'll see it pinches in here traffic
cues on the right there in that pulling
to let heavy lorries through we're
coming up to the blacksmith arm shortly
on the
left which is there and it's just from
here now that it's the foot path on the
left will be done away with look
at you see you can see he has to go on
the pavement to get by the foot path on
the right will be widened slightly and
we will have a five and a half meter
wide carriageway down here down to this
bridge
which is the Old Railway Bridge that
carries the Tet Trail over the top where
that Lor is in front there is a ramp
goes up there's a cycle H business there
here then this is Nutter Hill on the
left which we've just passed now it's
private from here on in but the
submitted transport assessment shows a
private 5 and a half meter wide road
with a 3 meter wide cycleway and foot
path uh there's no mention of that in
this in the uh in the
plan in the application now that's a
cafe on the left
there you know
and in one of the reports that um the
highway officer put in he said the links
with bidford Town
Center the links with bidford Town
Center are not very good and torington
Street as well as the bridge are not
conducive to sighting for many people
therefore 150,000 th is required to
towards improvements to cycle access
between the site and the Town Center I
don't know what's happened to that
either so there really are a lot of
questions I've got about the access and
as councelor Christie and councelor
craigy have raised it I think and I've
always this has always been my view of
this Brownfield site there should be a
new access road down from chuchill way
down into this site it would open all
kindo up for development the industrial
site jameston engineering at the far end
there's other industrial uses up that
far end what you're proposing is a a
housing estate with 96 homes for
families coming through an industrial
area and a builder yard almost Builder
supplies to get to this or or walking up
over the tker trail in the dark because
it's not proposed to light it um I just
think it's it's Dreadful and and as it
stands I'm I certainly can't support it
thanks Laura for putting that video
up anybody else like to make any
comments no more hands up Matt or
Michael if you'd like to come in and
answer a few of these issues about the
highway and
the and what's happened to the three
meter wide cycle wear and footway that
was proposed by the applicants in that
there's there's a number of questions
raised there I'll um I hopefully I can
address them all the I believe the three
and a half meter cycle route is between
the site proper up to what what is the
tarder um there's some other PL show
showing that uh from there you could
then join the T Trail using that access
that's already approved uh and then
carry on towards uh either this new ramp
down to ton Street or continue over the
bridge to uh the train station um and
into town that way or continue on to Bal
or insto um or continue on up to near
the doctor's surgery and come off there
pedestrians would have those same
options um as well as joining this the T
Trail
directly um rather than walking up to to
the yard to the juon area um the
proposed changes to torington Street
would keep the road width as it
currently is it's I think believe it's
already
5.5 the the works there would remove a
narrow footway on one side and create a
wider footway on the other side so we
would be getting one decent width 1.8
meter wide path instead of two narrow
paths that currently aren't suitable for
people with prams or wheelchairs um so I
consider that a betterment and and that
facilitates pedestrian access on on that
street
in terms of vehicle access I think you
are correct there there's a number of
issues with Ty the street but and there
are a number of other options that could
come forward but that's not the
application that is before us um that's
not proposed so considering what is here
they have submitted two transport
assessments um firstly you know back at
the beginning over 10 years ago um and
that work has been redone um in recent
years and resubmitted last year um if
any site in in bford is likely to be um
access to facilities and services on
foot or bicycle this this has to be it
it's it's a town center
location um with the chance for people
to do that to to facilities uh certainly
um more so than the large
other um developments in the area
especially considering some of the
topography towards Town Center you
similar level as the key um as you cross
cross to the facilities um and as as
I've mentioned those are the links to
the the train station or up to the
doctor's surgery and things on foot um
in terms of
numbers what what we've been looking at
is
approximately 35 to 40 Vehicles leaving
the site in the
morning most most likely onto that
roundabout via that that narrow route
that you've seen um and suggested here
less than 10 entering the site in the
morning and then the opposite way around
in the evening this is in terms of the
peak
hour and over the over the course of the
day um the applicant has suggested
around 200 250 Vehicles exiting and
similar number returning um mostly via
that that
roundabout when when you consider that
with all the other movements in the
areas Council leather said there are a
number of car garages uh the juic and
yard itself a number of properties
further beyond the site um and the
properties around nury Hill
um with those restrictions already in
place there are currently no recorded
vehicle collisions and we have no
evidence of any highway safety problems
um so when you when you consider that
against with the with the increase in
traffic against the national planning
policy framework policies and the local
plan policies
regarding access um and
safety you have
no evidence to suggest that the site is
unsafe and certainly have no evidence to
suggest that the site would be resulting
in severe congestion or delay as is
required by the plan and policy
framework paragraph 109
um and and members are aware number of
sites that that um we've discussed the
same matter on that is the test as to
whether you would refuse the application
on on access grounds uh as to whether it
is it is severe or not um I understand
it it will be frustrating it will be
inconvenient people having to wait and
let other people pass um you you may you
may Quee and wait to drive if you want
want to drive um there are options to to
walk in cycle as I've said um so you
don't have to
drive uh but when we consider that
against that severe
test I cannot see that that would be a
reason for refusal um I could could s
another other sites around the county
where where that has you know been
refused sites have been refused on that
um and
inspectors take a a firm line on that
that
severe um test uh in cases in ex to um
where you're adding you know hundreds of
meters of queuing and thousands of
vehicles are not considered severe you
this is an urban environment with other
opportunities to travel by non-car
mode um thank you Mark I can I I just
add the in the terms of the contribution
the um the secured 150,000 that you
mentioned the the that I requested
previously um I don't consider that's
needed anymore because of these proposed
Works in instead um and those links are
available right thank you I'll just
mention on page 77 of the report because
I've got a copy of the proposed access
road and as you see on the screen there
the new road shown going past juon and
around there's no 3 meter wide cycle way
or footway shown on that at all it's
been done away with and on page
77 paragraph 1 2 3 4 from the bottom
pedestrian and cycl access is confirmed
to be via new rants up to the TKA trail
from torington Street and back down to
the area near Jon's or onward on the TKA
Trail for access to the housing and I'll
just refer members to HR 1113 traffic
conflict of the Devon County Council
contrary to tr10 and that's in the Devon
County structure plan because there
isn't a definite conflict between
pedestrians and
vehicles for me on the access Shan in
torington street but councelor mcgoff
has got his hand up next to speak
councelor mcgoff
please thank I think um councel lck was
before me no councel you councel mof you
got your hand up okay I don't mind
talking chair I'm going to move that we
actually grab this application so poos
to grab this and thank you to the
highways officer for eleviating some of
my concerns obviously I am local I have
got a unit up near b u not the site
that's developed just where I parking
vehicle so I have no interest whatsoever
at any of the sites but um with the
removal of the pavement on the left hand
side past the blacks with arms that's
where the main congestion happens is
that point there because I travel every
day that with that going then
restriction there's no parking there at
all that takes I think that done in your
video scheme going through obviously I I
didn't attend the virtual site Vis
because I know the site very
well um and I think the highways offic
raise concern well raise the issue not
issue sorry the 1.8 meter path actually
the path of the right hand side going to
be extended for safety for the
pedestrians walking along that way um
I'd be more than happy to see this
development go through I I think it's
another River Frontage which should
hopefully complement the uh Bruns WF
development that's one side e what we
look at from the west side it actually
starts tied in the area up of Easter
water I understand the concerns about
the access point that's coming through
um um I think it needs to be better
managed from Devon County where their
enforcement offices if the development
goes through that's way you can stop
this issue or maybe the double yellow
lines going through with the lines of
the pavement to stop no parking at any
time that way you don't get no
congestion of traffic so i' I'd actually
move
for approval of this application thank
you thanks councelor mcov councelor
Craig is next to
speak oh thank you um I just
want I need to know that the children
who are walking to school through the
well it's like a rough car parking area
if they there must be a pavement and
there must be a well marked entrance to
duon because there's lorries and cars
coming in and out and you're just
proposing that children should walk
through a car park with Lor's coming in
and out and then there's the electric
the power station bit and other other
indust you you frozen there councelor
craigy can
I can I move on and I'll come back to
you councelor Craig um councelor lock
you've got your hand up to speak and
then I'll bring Matt Collins in again
yeah so um you can can the officer
confirm then that two out of the three
War counters in favor of this
application or the way that it's going
you know for the 106 agreement but going
back the highways um we saw the on that
virtual site visit and Laura has just
shown it again where the pavement is
going to be moved from the right hand
side to the left hand side but that's
where all the cars were parked so as
Council M goof has intimated are they
going to be double yellow lines then so
people can't par there can you perhap
show that video again for me
sorry sorry
Laura you'll cheer the people up in
torington Street even more if you ban
parking along
there this is the worst part for me as I
said on when we're looking before this
is the worst part of torington street
it's not when you get past the
blacksmith at all
and articulated lorries are coming and
going all day long into juic and they
actually swing around outside the yard
at ju right so this is where the
pavement is going to be swapped from the
right hand side to the left hand side no
from the left it'll be done away with
but the one on the right where that
Van's just driven over it be wi it'll be
widened so the left one will be gone and
you see the there yellow lines along
here I think
it's single yellow line there so you
can't part there in the day
um you you can't park there in the day
but at night you can after six o'clock
of
course this is a bad junction on the
left but nothing's been made of that at
all it's a terrible Junction now this
year in front of Jon's now Arctic Lor is
swing around outside here councelor
craigy was talking about that it's a
very busy build as much people coming
and going all day and this is where the
private road should be going
through so there are yellow line there
are Yow lines already in that area
single yellow single yellow lines thank
you I come in here
CH yeah thanks Matt um just got a couple
of things to to mention here um you
mentioned policy
st10 I believe was it st10 or tr10 of
the 10 year conflict the Deon structure
plan now that that plan that plan was
voked um with the introduction of the
national planning policy framework so
that policy that's an out-of-date policy
um I assume that was a previous uh
colleague of mine dealing with the
application when it first came in it's
still on the Devon County Council
website when you print off the their
document on highways it may be still in
some of the old documents but yeah but
the the the government have revoked that
that policy well there is a conflict in
any event yeah and and and it's the
national planning policy framework and
your local plan policies that are the
relevant ones
to in terms of double yellow lines as
you've seen there are restrictions there
um during the day um the you could
condition that the applicant looks into
further measures however you couldn't
condition that they are uh definitely or
certainly approved because that's
subject to further legislation um and as
you mentioned that housing living there
as we've seen in the previous um
application today um generally they they
Park on that street
um in terms of the walking route to the
school if Laura could change the plan to
show a slightly wider
view people pedestrians and cyclist
don't need to walk through the juice and
yard area at all um pretty that's quite
small so so further to the South near
the site there's a there's a proposed
car park for uh public use uh as as well
as a link there onto the T
Trail they they could they could go onto
the T Trail there and then travel
North and and either come off look can
move move to the north they could EI
they would
avoid yes they go um they can go that
way North
past zoom zooms out there so so you can
go past the yard area on the T Trail
there on on in the center and down that
new ramp that's proposed and then along
Torrington Street where we've seen just
seen the video or and then up noty hill
or torington Lane as people would in the
um housing in that area at the moment
and up quite considerable steep uh Road
up to the school as as as people
currently do or they could continue on
uh considerable way but around a More
Level access continue on the T Trail and
come around um bartville Street and up
up through Mante away that way it's
considerably longer or um or access the
uh bus service um along boun
Street there are there are options for
people to be able to get to the school
safely without having to to use that
yard thanks M it's fair to say that the
foot path on the new proposed Road has
been done away with the three meter wide
cycle way and footway I I believe the
the only cycle way that that is
between juicen and the site so it's not
through that juice and yard it would be
to the south of that and I say I'm not
I'm not certain what benefit that has
considering you would then have to cycle
through the yard um um and and the
alternative of using the tar Trail is
there so I'm not not
certain right thanks Sean Sean you want
to come in here thank you Council Le all
I just wanted to
clarify sorry um was the policy
framework because it has been mention of
revoked policies and with the
discussions in relation to highways just
to highlight to plans committee members
as they'll be aware that the policies
that they need to be looking at um if
they were minded to make any decision
would be uh the mppf paragraph
109 um the policy st10 particularly
paragraph e um OB adopted North to Joint
local plan and policy
dmo5 um par L I think it's one just BR
me for a
second yeah policy DMO 51 which states
that all development must ensure safe
and welld designed vehicle access erress
adequate parking and layouts which
considered the needs and accessibility
of all highway users including cyclists
and pedestrians so that's the um that's
the policy framework that members may
want to be looking at thank you thank
you Sean councelor craiger you froze a
minute ago when you're speaking would
you like to come back again oh thank you
um I was just saying that I think people
when people are in a hurry they always
take a direct route they're not likely
to take to go in the opposite direction
to stroll up the Tet trail with and a
roundabout route they'll take the
shortest route so that means that people
will be walking through what is
essentially an open rough car park and
must I can't support the development
unless as a pavement from the bridge
because the bit before the bridge is bad
enough but it's got a pavement after the
bridge there must be a pavement through
the site there must be a clear access to
duon because people have got to walk
past that um at the moment it's just a
rough open area with no defined Road or
pavement or parking
spaces and so I I just I can't support
the development until there's a pavement
through there for the children to go to
school yeah and and to use the just the
Tet Trail as being the only pedestrian
and cycle way but certainly for
pedestrian it's not lit in the winter
time after 4:00 when it's dark nobody
wants to walk along there in the dark
there's no proposal to light the Tet
trail and I doubt that that would be
supported it's be very prominent if you
put Street lighting along there but it's
not proposed in any event and I am dis
you know I am surprised that the new
access road will not have a foot path
along it to the new development it was
proposed by Council mcof but nobody's
setting that proposal to Grant I can't
support it I I shall be supporting this
application because I do think despite
what Matt said on Highway grounds I I'll
I'll second it for councel M you're
second thanks Council I've listened to
it all now and I'll second it to approve
councel a lot you've put your hand
up you I was I was going to Second the
application but be got there before me
all right unless anybody else has
anything to discuss it been proposed to
Grant by councelor mcgoff secondly by
councelor
Watson to Grant um so Sandra if you
could go to the vote
please yes chair councelor bowon yeah
for to Grant councelor Brown against
councelor chrisy against councelor
craigy against councelor leather against
councelor lock four councelor
mcgoff four councelor Watson
four councelor wisman four
chair that's five for and four
against thank you Sandra thanks for
that right now we've got a 30 minute
break schedule now and I could do with a
break to be honest I'm sure everybody
else for for those just one moment
please for those who are watching on
YouTube we've got a scheduled bre break
of half an hour now which will take us
back we'll be back at 12 o'clock at
midday um so if you'd like to join us at
midday or stay on I think we'll stay
Live on YouTube but we'll be back at 12
o'clock to continue the meeting thank
you thank you chair I'm gonna mute
everybody now as
well
right everybody I hope everybody's back
in it's 12
o'l
GNA put me dinner in the oven done an
online shop at the local
shop
R councelor Watson's disappeared I see
he's probably gone to other
he' have had more than one I think
Rose in the
time oh he's coming there we are live c
yeah it is 12 o'clock welcome back
everybody welcome back the rest of the
committee and officers uh we move on
then with our
planning meeting the next application
we've got is application wner
0460 2020 it's a full application the
three dwellings Hampton Park rally Hill
and I think Helen's doing this I
believe yes um good good morning
councilors good afternoon good afternoon
councelors sorry um yeah th this
application um proposes well it's made
in full and it proposes residential
development of three dwellings um it is
it is a departure from the local plan
and has been advertised accordingly also
with a site notice put up um and there
are there are no no updates so I'll move
on to the presentation thank
you so this is the submitted site
location plan um you can see the applic
site is outlined in red um access is
achieved via rally Hill which forms the
northern boundary of the
site I'm just moving on to an aerial
photo now um the site is outlined in in
red um it is technically within the open
Countryside um I I'll later show um a
proposals map the the proposals ma
members can appreciate the relationship
with the built form um it's it the land
slopes to towards the north um down
towards the
a39 um Hampton Park which is the the
series of Residential Properties
immediately to the East and the west and
south of the site is is also undeveloped
Country Side the site also slopes
upwards from the north to the
South this is um an arrow photo which
shows just a wider area so the site is
highlighted with an orange out line and
and dashed in pink it's just to give
members an appreciation of how how the
application site relates to both bed and
Northern it's technically within
Northern Ward um however obviously
relates to the built form of of bford as
well the the Red Dot to the north of the
site is the scheduled ancient mon
Monument the Lenwood ball Barrow um I've
just highlighted this for members
because unlike previous applications
that were considered on this site
historic England have flagged this up in
respect of this application and further
information was requested from the
applicant which um which was submitted
um historic England do rais no
objections to the impact on the
scheduled ancient
Monument this is an extract from the
local plan proposals map it's prop
proposals map two which relates to
bidford you can see the site is outlined
in red um and is outside of but adjacent
to the development boundary it therefore
technically Falls within the open
Countryside and is subject to policy
st7 so now just looking at going through
some
photos the first two show views towards
the site so this is from the north um
you can see it's it's the the Green
Field immediately above the the plowed
field and Hampton Hampton Park you can
see immediately to the to the east of
the site you to the
left and this is a view sort of from the
north northwest looking towards the site
again the immediate properties facing
towards the camera are um that is H
Hampton Park and you can sort of see the
established hedge r that forms the the
northern boundary of the
site so this um this just shows the road
approach the rally Hill approaching the
application site the application site is
actually just around the corner um but
it just just to appreciate the the
nature of the access
road and this is again sort of rally
Hill the site is immediately on the
right here the um the hedge row with
with sort of the various trees planted
along it that is the the northern
boundary of the site and you can just
make out properties of Hampton Court
Beyond Hampton Park sorry
Beyond now just looking at more detailed
photos of the site which members will
have will have seen sort of in in a
video at the virtual site meeting this
is the existing access the existing
entrance into the site this would be
widened and visibility improved for the
new development to
proceed again s of just inside the
entrance looking at the site you can
appreciate how it how it slopes upwards
from north to south it's currently used
for the grazing of horses keeping of
horses so now looking from within the
site towards the north you can
appreciate the the existing treed
boundary along the northern element and
the the nature of sort of existing
structures and um boundaries within the
site um and now just sort of panning
around this is looking towards the
Northeast um the sort of nearest
property on on H in Hampton Park you can
see just just there within the center of
the photograph that's actually on r h
all right sorry yeah sorry councelor
you're right so this then shows um the
the nearest property on Hampton Hampton
Park and yes you're right Bradley Hill
below so now just continuing to pan
round this looking towards the
east um so the two properties that would
sit adjacent to the development within
Hampton Park you can now now see within
the
photo and then looking up to the South
um a sort of appreciate appreciating how
the land do slope
upwards and then moving around to the
Southwest the
west and then back around to the
Northwest so again that's the boundary
with rally Hill and moving on to some
the the submitted drawings now this is
the survey drawing that was submitted
commed um it does emphasize that the
change in levels from North moving
through to the south of the
site and this is the proposed the
proposed site plan so access would be
achieved in the same location as the
existing entrance with visibility
improved um the application proposes
three detached dwellings with their own
parking and amenity space there's also a
sign significant amount of additional
Landscaping proposed both in the form of
enhancements to the existing hedge rows
along the north and the west and a new
hedge R along the South and and partly
around the East along with additional
tree planting and um sort of wild wild
Meadow planting as well
um just looking at this the the distance
between plot one and the two
dwellings on on Hampton Park um you're
looking at a distance of 29 M and 37 M
respectively now going into the specific
drawings for each plot um all three of
the dwellings are arranged with li
living accommodation at the upper upper
level and they all have um sort of a
bridge access from the the open plans of
living dining area out to a garden um
utilizing the change in levels as the
site moves southwards um they also all
have render and Timber boarding
elevations natural slate roofs and
aluminum doors and windows so plot one
is a three-bedroom dwelling orbe it's
one there is a study identified as well
plot two um is a proposed four bed
dwelling again they all have attach
garages and external parking and then
plot three is again a similar design but
a larger dwelling proposing five
bedrooms um and then finally the the
site Falls within the chem withth
critical drainage area um the
application is supported by a drainage
strategy this plan shows how surface
water will be dealt with the submitted
strategy refers to the drainage
hierarchy and um evidence has been
provided to show that on-site
infiltration is not possible
um and that the the O the the best and
only option is connection into the
surface water sewer so this this drawing
shows
that so now finally moving on to the the
main material planning considerations
for this proposal so in respect of the
principle of development the site is
located in the open Countryside however
as as members of the committee are aware
um we currently as an author Authority
cannot demonstrate a five-year land
supply of housing therefore as per the
mppf the decision is to be made on the
basis of the Tilted balance um I should
also emphasize that policy st21 which
allows sites to come forward adjacent to
development boundaries um your officers
consider that that policy is satisfied
so the conflict with st7 is reduced um
so it's it's the decision needs to be
taken on the basis of whether the the
identified harm demonstr demonstrably
and significantly outweighs the benefits
of The Proposal looking at the specific
sort of
technical points in respect of the
application a very detailed landscape
mitigation scheme is proposed and it's
proposed for that to be secured via a
legal agreement um you'll have seen
there's quite an extensive summary of
the previous consideration of similar
proposals on this site um with the tree
office uh I've his his comments are
provided again raising no objection and
indeed two inspectors considering
considering that with the landscape
mitigation there is no objection on
landscape grounds um Heritage impacts a
condition is recommended to require a
written scheme of Investigation as per
Devon County council's um historic
environment team to request historic
England are raising no objections in
terms of impacts on the Lenwood Barrow
Bowl um and additional information has
been provided by the applicant on that
there aren't considered to be any
objections in respect of residential
amenity or highways as set out in the
report and as um as communicated by both
previous appeal inspectors in respect of
ecology um significant enhancements are
proposed to to achieve a net gain in
biodiversity at the site and it's
recommended that these measures are
secured via condition as well as a
condition preventing external lighting
unless other unless agreed in
writing um surface water drainage I've
already sort of explained both will be
connected into the the existing
networks the in respect of planning
obligations the the site Falls beneath
the requirement for Education
contributions and affordable housing it
does however trigger a need for off-site
open space contributions as set out in
the report which would be secured via a
legal agreement and in discuss with
Northern Town Council um so in respect
of the Tilted
balance um and with reference to policy
sd21 and with regard to the the two
previous appeal inspector's decisions
which are material considerations it's
considered that the the benefits of the
scheme I.E the economic and social
benefits arising from the construction
of three
dwellings um particularly given we
currently are unable to demonstrate a
five-year land Supply um those benefits
are not outweighed by any other material
considerations and therefore the
recommendation is one of approval
subject to a legal agreement to secure
landscape mitigation and open space
contributions thank you Helen thanks for
that well we've got two speakers for
this
application
um the first speaker is Mike Jordan who
to speak against it if if Mr Jordan is
here I don't believe Mr Jordan is here
Council l so I do have his
representation to read out yeah all
right Sean thank you for that if you
will chair members of the plan planning
committee my name is Michael Jordan and
I'm a resident of Hampton Park which is
next to the proposed development I have
to ask a question why do we have
planning department and why are we
holding a planning committee if all an
applicant needs to do is mention
Five-Year Plan and the approval is
rubber stamped
I'm sure this is what members of the
public believe as does this applicant
this want and destruction in the
countryside has to stop somewhere T used
to be to quote the saying a quaint
little town no longer as councilors you
have been selected by members of torage
to represent them for good of torage as
members of the plan committee you have
volunteered to undertake and look after
these interests and therefore as its
proposal is outside the designated
development plan a plan approved by this
very committee surely it must be refused
if on appeal the planning inspector
grants permission so be it but at least
you can hold your heads up high sleep at
night knowing you did your part to the
best of your ability chair members of
the committee thank you for
listening thank you Sean and the next
speaker for this is Katherine Nee
speaking in support member of the public
it says is Katherine n available is she
written in uh Council I think um
Katherine has uh removed her um request
to speaker at this committee all right
thank you
chair right well that's the last of the
public speakers on this so counselor
christe if you'd like to start on this
one thank you yes um real sense to Deja
Vu here uh we've had this application
twice we've turned it down twice it's
been to appeal twice they've lost twice
and the only reason it's come back today
of course is the change in the fiveyear
land
Supply uh but just because we don't have
a fiveyear land Supply doesn't mean we
have to support every speculative
reapplication like this um the last
member of the public whose um letter was
read out I think picked up on that
point now we turned it down before on
slightly odd grounds actually I thought
where I actually said the grounds we
should turn it down on is the most
obvious one of at thought of all if you
could bring the map back up of where the
site
is
that that one will do it's not quite the
one I wanted but this site is surrounded
on three sides by Open
Fields um it is in the open Countryside
I I don't I haven't seen a you know a
clearer case of this for a long time uh
you may recall we had an application
again in bord over the edge of London
der state where the site was bounded on
one side by an open field and that went
to appeal and the inspector said it was
in the open Countryside this one has
Open Fields on three sides you can see
it is sorry sorry chair and sorry
counselor Christy um can we just pause
just for a moment there's a problem with
YouTube so I just want to make sure that
we're we're still
live it does say Live on YouTube at the
top of my screen it does I've just
received a message to say it's not
showing so just just bear with us for a
couple of minutes
chair
you weren't on the committee
when no last
time I spoke against it for 10
G chy said it was tur on whil we're
waiting is it possible for the officer
to go back another map to show the uh
area in more detail we're good chair
we're we're back con all right thank
you yes there we are that's the uh the
Google Earth view you can see the site
is completely surrounded by open
Countryside um and I would uh quote what
Northern Town Council said about this
because on page 95 of our agenda there's
quite a long um piece about this but
there's one sentence which I think sums
this up uh this is a creeping form of
sporadic development into open
Countryside
which should be
refused and I trust it will be refused
for the third time and I do reiterate
just because we lack fiveyear land
Supply doesn't mean we have to accept
every reapplication that comes in and
this is one just the three houses thank
you thank you counselor Christie
councelor
lock yeah I was just going to say what
um C Christie said just because we
haven't got a 5year land Supply because
if you read the last paragraph up on
page
99 yeah i' got that highlighted yeah for
the purposes of presumption policies of
the development plan are not considered
automatically to be out of date by virt
have not been able to demonstrate the
fiveyear land Supply whether a policy is
out of date is a matter for the decision
taker so I think you know the decision
as a committee is in our hands but also
on the second um application that was
turned down um both by committee and
appeal they talked about maintenance and
management agreement I still don't see
that that's in place anyway which I
thought they would have done with their
third
application any comments on that Helen
please yes so the the required um
management and maintenance agreement
that would form part of the unilateral
undertaking so a draft of that was
prepared in support of the previous
appeal um it would if the application
were to be approved today um you as with
any um application that is recommended
subject to a legal agreement there would
then need to be before any decision is
issued um that that legal agreement
would be finalized and it would it would
now need to include an open space
contribution as well so um the fact that
there isn't a signed version in front of
the committee today is is not you know
that wouldn't be a reason to refuse it
um the the first appeal inspector did
turn it down for that reason um but an
appeal is a very sort of different
different scenario to um you know a
resolution by plans committee so um
members can take comfort that such an
agreement um is is very much in draft
but would be finalized before any
decision is
issued thank you
Helen well there's no other hand up to
speak so I'll check my bit in when this
twice as as councelor Christie said
twice came to plans committee I wasn't
on torage at the time twice refused
twice refused on appeal despite officers
recommend and
approval uh I spoke against it as a
representative of Northern Town Council
at the time and as Council locks pointed
out just because we've not got the
fiveyear housing land Supply doesn't
automatically mean every little scheme
that comes forward in open Countryside
should be should be
approved these three four and five
bedroom houses do add hardly anything to
our lack of a housing Supply but they do
a great deal of damage as far as I'm
concerned to the open Countryside and
that was mentioned by one of the
inspectors too the the development would
conflict with the policies in the
development plan and emerging policies
this is at the time in terms of the
strategy for locating new housing it is
a little Country Lane up there that you
could see from the photographs and to
add it more sticking out into the
countryside like that like a sort of
thumb very
visible um for me is is I've not changed
my opinion at all it um despite the five
year housing land suppli the decision is
ours and I'm going to move from the
chair that it's refused chair uh members
councel Watson you've got your hand up
to speak yeah yes chair I can't agree
with you chair sorry but um on page
93 at the bottom the last paragraph
right at the bottom where it it
describes the the fa appeal and the
second appeal now the second appeal um
was because we had a fiveyear land
Supply and for basically and um
dismissed for that reason we' have got
the the management plan as uh Ellena
said so that that is fine which was made
in um the the reason for failure in the
first first appeal so now we've got that
and the first appeal was you know was
was just noting that um that should be
there and and it the development was
okay so now we've got the management
plan and we haven't got a five-year land
Supply so my belief is that if this is
refused it'll go to
appeal and um and and and get approved
and
also on page 95 I I've read what
Northern Town Council and they must beh
old that that as well because one part
of it says a large site behind rally
Hill with access onto Haywood Road was
as planning permission for 180 houses
there is no need for further Housing
Development on this very restricted
Access Road well I'm sorry we ain't got
to we haven't got to place there with
with 180 hour is going to be built
because it it's it's passed it's gone so
how can we have enough then I I just
don't understand that and and I would
beg to differ that for me I will propose
that we we approve
it it's still a sight in the in the
development plan that one that last will
be but but they're not building there
right councelor
wisman very
much can't hear can't hear you your
sounds again
is that no no no we can't
hear we can't hear
it happened terrible sorry Council
wisman we can't hear anything no still
nothing that's a bit
[Music]
better we' we've lost you counselor one
he
we couldn't hear anything
there anybody else want to contribute to
the debate on
this well I've moved that it be refused
as it's contrary to
st7 and it does not add I'll second it
Chris thank you councelor
Christie Sean you want to come
in uh yeah thank you chair um just to
highlight like um something that
councelor chrisy said which is
absolutely correct that um the lack of
5,000 land Supply doesn't mean that we
obviously rubber stamp um every
application that comes before us and you
know that's absolutely right um however
what we do need to do is take into
account the Tilted balance um as we
previously discussed in the mppf and
therefore articulate in um any
discussions and any decision that's made
um The Tilted balance and the benefits
of the scheme and the impact of the
scheme as well as being cont to various
policies um if the members feel that's
the
case thank thank you Sean um yeah I will
because I did mention the Tilt I didn't
actually mention tilted balancer shut
but that was a I was alluding to when I
mentioned this is in the open
Countryside and and the the so-called
benefits of it which I can't see much of
a benefit for the area at all is is
outweighed by the detrimental
harm that this does to the open
Countryside three houses is a negligible
contribution if it was for 10 or 15 or
20 a site somewhere a joining the
development bound it might be a
different thing it adds but three luxury
dwellings had nothing in my opinion and
and do not tilt the balance in favor of
this development councelor wisman got
see if we working now that's better
that's better we can um right well I was
just going to say I agree with Council
Watson to be perfectly be honest um it
doesn't matter how large the house is or
how luxurious it is a house is still
counted as one house and they all add at
the fiveyear land Supply we have to be
con we have to have some consistency
here we've recently approved houses uh
developments that have been in open
Countryside without too much of a
conscience about it and I think we need
to carry on in the same milk until we
hit that fiveyear land
Supply I think I think Richard is
talking about the three thanks thanks
councelor Watson councelor
mcof thank you very much Mr chairman
yeah after listening to what Sean Haron
said and Council WISN and Council Watson
I will second councelor Watson's
proposal to cor the
application goodness
sake thank you very much for the
goodness sake don't forget you're Live
on YouTube you have a bit of
manners thank you councelor mcof well
nobody else wants to speak we'll take
the first proposal which I propose to
refuse because it's cont to st7
councelor Chris is second it so Sandra
could you take that vote
please yes
chair councelor
Bon yeah
four councelor Brown
against councelor Christie oh
councelor
craigy I'm abstaining I don't know what
to
do councelor leather
for councelor
lock you're muted councelor
lock
against councelor
mcof
against councelor Watson against
councelor wisman
[Music]
against CH that's three for the
application five against and one
abstention thank you
Sandra now we take the second proposal
which proposed by councelor Watson I
don't think we have to chair do yeah we
got the vote on councelor Watson
proposed that we GR the application and
was it councelor mcof seconded
it yes I second yeah Sandra if you take
that vote please yes chair councilor Bon
against then councelor Brown
against councelor chrisy
against councelor
craigy abstain
councelor leather
against councelor lock
for councelor mcgoff four councelor
Watson four councelor wisman
or chair that vote was for for four
against and one
abstention I thought that was five could
you those votes again please I made it
five
for no four four against one abstention
and four in
favor yeah um I can read out the um
councilors who voted for were councelor
lock councelor mcgoff councelor Watson
and councelor wisman yeah those that
voted against application were councelor
bowon councelor Brown councelor chrisy
and councelor leather and councelor
craigy
abstained right well I'm casting my
Chairman's vote
against so it's it's neither been
approved nor
refused
um
it's been refused chair because you you
have a casting
vote it's been refused
yeah yeah so it it is it is refused
isn't it that's
it yeah if you put your cast in vote um
the application has been refused yeah
thank you Sandra yeah I was just getting
my head round the fact that the way the
voting me but yet it is refused and
thank
you right we move on
then chair chair sorry can I can I just
in intervene um
St I don't think the uh it's been
refused it's just not been approved
we've had two motions the first motion
was your motion Council L the proposal
to refuse that didn't go
ahead and then the second was the
proposal to approve and that hasn't gone
ahead um I I use M casting vote then
against
it that that wasn't for the approval
chair that was for the refusal
yeah
so no my casting vote was used when when
it was proposed to approve it and I
voted against it and I used my casting
vote to vote against
it so it's lost could I speak chair
please no no we're gonna move on it's
been voted against that's
it okay I don't agree with you but okay
move you move on we'll move on then to
our next
application sorry Council L can I very
quickly
um Lee vote for approval lost but we
haven't got wording for the words for
refusal and the reasons for refusal the
policies that um committee fi country we
had that we had that in the first round
of voting uh which was lost but we
haven't had this in the second round of
voting for the
approval so what what I'm essentially
what I'm looking for is I'm looking for
a reason for refusal the wording of that
reason for refusal and the associated
policies um which I don't think we've
had a vote on just looking towards the
senior
L right
okay well I mean councelor Christie
wants to speak let me bring councelor
Christie in a minute yeah can I just
suggest if you're looking for a policy
this is the one that uh development in
the open
Countryside uh that's the one that's
going to be fought at appe I think
that's the strongest ground I would
agree with that
yeah and sorry and does that also
include the comments about the Tilted
balance that counc committee discussed
earlier on in this discussion that was
key to the the Tilted balance discussion
that it country side was the main
thing
yeah
okay we'll move on then to our next
application which
is when I turn the right page
over chair could we just um have a
proposal on a seconder for for that
please for what just just what refusal
for the refusal on those
grounds well it was it was proposed to
it was proposed to approve
it and I used a casting vote against it
the reasons given of the the ones to do
with open Countryside the put our
policies on the open Countryside having
considered the Tilted
balance all right happy with
that
let's move on
then page
123 is our next
application cancel a
lock I was just GNA make a comment about
when when you Goot to
st7 and the Tilted balance that should
have been on your refusal proposal not
on the
approval
um votes should
I just to muddy the waters even further
I mentioned that Council a lot to to
Sean Harrington and he said he didn't
think we could put that in again because
that was the reason that we get I given
for refusal in the first instance I
don't see why we can't put st7 back in
as well as the ones to do with it
countrycide policies to do with itton
countrycide
I'm sure the st7 ought to be in there
anyway we'll move on we'll move on to
our next
application application
10398 2020 is a full application um at
rally Hill again and and I think if
Ryan's not here I think Helen might be
presenting this as well uh no it is me
chair um Ryan you here are you yeah I am
here I can confirm my presence lovely
thank you thank you um so just before I
proceed obviously the application is for
the construction of one dwelling um at
briber rally
Hill um since the committee report has
been published I should make you aware
that the council have received two more
objections uh one of these objections
has been requested to be read out which
I obviously confirmed with you yesterday
so I'll just read that out
now just to interrupt they are both on
the planning portal as well yeah they
they are by public on the portal um they
were uploaded as of the 1st of September
thanks Ryan okay so uh to the torch
District Council planning committee I am
Angela toly and reside at Mahana which
borders the above proposed application I
would like to submit a strong objection
to this on the grounds that our property
will be severely overlooked including
our garden and private imunity areas the
proposed property is very close to the
boundary of our own with Windows
directly overlooking our property we
feel strongly that this development will
material affect our right to privacy
neither myself nor my neighbor Joyce
Williams who resides at courland have
been consulted on this application with
no written Communications received it is
only by chance that the neighbor
mentioned it in passing whil out that we
became aware of the application hence
this late objection Joyce is very
elderly frail and lives on her own with
no computer access but I have scanned
and attached her objection as well can
you please read this out at the planning
meeting on Thursday the 3rd of September
con regards Angela T
right as we move through the uh
committee presentation so this is a site
location it's it's uh located sort of
centrally on Robins Hill which is to the
south of rally
Hill this is the location plan the site
is indicated Edon
red uh this is a view on Robin Hill uh
sort looking on south to
North and this again is an image of
Robins
Hill uh looking up towards the
application site with uh this sort of
garden here on your right hand side
where that's uh the immunity part of the
immunity area for for Hayworth
house this is at the top of the site um
looking towards the back of the property
known as
bramber um as you can see it's quite
overgrown this is sort of Taken
centrally towards the application site
so this is the East View towards hay
with house house in the background and
and the boundary treatments as you can
see and this is a Southeast view with
that cladded dwelling that is uh mitel
house and this is a view towards the top
of the
site
uh
yeah and this is a view uh along the
western boundary of the
site I thought because of the uh
application design but it's quite a
contemporary design I thought it might
be relevant to to provide some images of
some uh surrounding dwellings so you've
got brambo and MIT house
there and because of some of the
objections related to uh overlooking of
hay with house I provided some of the
immunity areas of hay with house some of
which are are largely screened uh from
from views from the application
site and now we move on to the drawings
this is uh the block
plan and these are the
elevations as you can see um just
relating to those objections that we've
had from Mahana and courland along the
western boundary uh it's worth noting
that the first floor windows on the
western elevation of the property are
frosted
glazing and this is the floor plan for
the proposal which uh shows a three
bedroon
property and the material plan
considerations in this case are the
principle of development um obviously
the SES located within the development
boundary um of the area and obviously
we've got we've talked about the 5D land
supply issues uh design and character
impact it's a quite contemporary
dwelling because there's a sort of fluid
arrangement with sort of balance between
traditional properties and and and the
Contemporary ones that I've shown within
the slides uh the residential imunity
issues we've talked
about um with approximately 30 m
difference between the application site
and the uh property Hayward house which
has uh had quite a few objections and
similar distances uh to courland and
Mahana properties uh highways and
parking uh during site visits we talked
about the issue of uh part of the road
being private and there were questions
about whether the the the uh applicant
could provide some improvements to that
road I've discussed this with the agent
um but it's not really proportionate to
the to the development of one dwelling
to seek uh these
improvements um uh drainage and
ecology thank you thank you chair and I
will take any
questions thank you Ryan well with' two
two speakers listed for this one the
first speaker is Andy Jones I think he's
present and you've got three minutes
thank you Mr Jones I am can you hear me
okay thanks yeah fine thank okay good
okay so good morning thank you for the
opportunity to speak uh I'm Andy Jones I
live at Hayworth house uh which borders
the application site at bramber um I
strongly object this application and
firmly believe it should be rejected um
there are numerous issues with it I've
read the report by Ryan steppel um and
disagree with it in a number of areas
firstly I think should be noted that
Northern Town Council planning committee
refused this
unanimously um due to reasons of
overlooking um the lack of contextual
drawings fail to show the 3 meter height
difference between uh the application
site and hay with house um which means
that we'll be severely overlooked
including our well-used community areas
and will have sight lines into several
building uh several bedrooms including
my children um I think the planning
officer in his report has been very
generous to the applicant um as there is
no doubt that unaccepted able
overlooking will occur contrary to the
adopted policy dmo1 immunity
considerations um it's not simply a
matter of distance as implied in the
agenda item uh to introduce a two-story
dwelling with Windows and balconies
where nothing was present before uh will
result in overlooking no matter what
screening um and um uh other HED RS are
put in place um Ward counselor Manley
has seen the site in person and is in
complete agreement ment with my own and
my neighbor concerns regarding
overlooking um and it's for this reason
that she made the formal call in for it
to be discussed at committee
level um further the character of the
area is one of um substantial dwellings
um each set within very set within very
generous
grounds um and if even if you just look
on the front cover of the report you
will see that virtually every other site
every other uh house has got generous
Gardens and it's very constrained site
and is out of character um and that goes
in contravention of dmo4 character and
design
impact um in many respects I feel that
this is um this application reflects the
excess of garden grabbing in
contravention of the government's
planning policy guidance note
ppg3 um this recognizes that the spaces
between dwellings are as important as
the character as the um as the dwellings
themselves um it's an important
consideration which I think has been
completely overlooked by the pro
proposer
um I should also add um it will have
negligible negligible contribution on
the five-year housing
Supply so um finally I just like to note
as well this is the fourth application
to build a dwelling on this site
previous applications in
1983 2002 have been rejected and the
last application in 2019 has been
withdrawn before it could be rejected as
well so in summary I think there are
sound reasons to refuse the application
um which should be consistent with the
council sound determination of previous
submissions to arrive at a different
view I think is not Justified on sound
planning grounds thank you for listening
thank you Mr Jones Thank you and our
next speaker against it is Mr cob and
he's he's here so Mr cob you've got
three minutes as well please to give us
your presentation if you unmute yourself
uh I am lovely thank you yeah that's it
you can hear me well now yeah good okay
um good morning and thank you for your
time um I'm Howard carb I live at Myrtle
house which is directly opposite the
application site of bramber and would
actually be the closest building to it I
strongly object this application and
believe it should be rejected I've read
the report by Ryan steppel and disagree
with its conclusion in several areas but
there are two there are two areas in
particular as with previous applications
for this property I've pointed out the
site plans carry no information on the
base elevation of the proposed property
thus it's impossible to judge exactly at
what height this property will finish in
relation to the surrounding
properties because of this lack of
information you can only guess from the
drawings its actual position but it
appears that the applicant has proposed
situation the building as far away as
possible from his own which is
bramber and at the highest point on the
site which is also as close as it could
possibly be to the road and my home this
would result in the proposed dwelling
severe overlooking our family property
including our small but well-used garden
and decking area as well as having sight
lines into several bedrooms and our
dining area in addition the front of the
proposed house has a balcony on the
first floor where the potential
residents could sit and Overlook us
Overlook us at their
Leisure uh I believe that Ryan steppel
has been remiss in regards to Myrtle
house in this
respect in his report as the northern
planning committee raised concerns
specific specifically in regards to the
overlooking of Myrtle house but he's
failed to mention Myrtle house in his
residential imunity
statement and concentrated solely on
Hayworth house to the
right I'm particularly annoyed at the
prospect of my Outlook becoming a new
house looking down down on my property
as until immediately before the first
application for this build was lodged
the garden boasted approximately 10
mature beautiful healthy trees which
were cut down for no apparent reason
just before the application went in so I
I recommend that you refuse this due to
the issue of overlooking um and and I
fully believe that thank you for your
time you're muted councelor
leather yeah sorry sorry everybody yeah
thank you Mr cob for that uh that was
was our last speaker on this so uh it's
open to the committee now and councelor
lot you've got your hand
up no I did that by mistake sorry I'll
come in later on all right
uh anybody else want to speak or
councelor
Christie yeah can I just ask our officer
in his presentation he talked about um
vegetation between this new development
and ha
house um yet I couldn't see any pictures
of it uh is there any vegetation there
because I've walked up here quite often
as I supect you have count of leather
because we live in this area um can I
ask what is the vegetation uh between
the two houses because if it does act as
a screen or not um I'm bit unclear on
that also I'm slightly worried that uh
the last gentleman who spoke said that
his house isn't mentioned in the uh the
details we've had and yet it is the
nearest one to it could that be
explained as
well hi counselors um so I'm a bit um
unfamiliar what you're asking um but
what I would say is that we have put a
condition on condition four which ask
for further detail subsequent to any
approval here today about landscape
so um it just to ensure that you know if
it was approved that any any land any
Landscaping treatments would be improved
and retained as part of uh the future
um what was the other question that you
asked councelor it was Ryan it was
looking at the photographs you've put
back up now the one on the left is the
parking area for howth house and the
fence shown along is the boundary
between bramber the new dwelling there
and to the just slightly to the left of
that tree is the site that we're talking
about your photograph on the right is
I'm not sure what that's a view of
actually that's a view of um the front
garden I believe of Hayworth
house right okay thank you showing so it
shows it shows that sorry to interject
so it shows that uh that there are many
private parts of Hayworth house that
would would still be private as even
after this application would be approved
um and the image on the left shows
that the views that um the objector is
concerned about regarding Hayworth house
is already visible via the road on uh
Robins
Hill right yeah so Council Lether can I
just come back on that yes certainly can
to Chris um when the officer did his
presentation he actually mentioned there
was vegetation between the two houses ha
house and the new one that would act as
a screen and I now hear that this will
be subject to Landscaping in the future
um either that's looking up the hill uh
either there is vegetation there that is
going to act as a screen or there isn't
um it's all very well saying there's
going to be Landscaping in the future um
my second question was why as the last
uh speaker said why there was no mention
his house when it does appear to be the
closest so as you can see this block
plan here does show um head R along
along the boundary for the application
so you've got the head R to uh the the
West sorry the East where howth house is
here I
can so give you little there so they
have shown uh boundary treatments and a
tree um for for on on the application on
on the Block plan sorry but it's just
it's just that we we would seek uh F
further detail on that
aspect okay so sorry Council leather can
I just come back and say that if that
picture you couldn't identify and I
don't know where it is if that's meant
to be the screening vegetation and we've
already heard that it's a 3 meter
difference then that scrubby little
hedge isn't going to act as any
protection from
overlooking um and I did ask you know
why the other house hasn't been
mentioned as the the as the gentleman
said I also noticed that the balcony is
on the uh Eastern side it isn't
overlooking brano which is the
applicant's
house well well it does actually you can
look from that balcony there into the
back of
Brammer that balcony
there which is an Upstairs Lounge that
Sean
there thank you it's not a balcony it's
part of the lounge but it sticks out
yeah
Sean thank you Council Le um yeah just
to um clarify that issue with regard to
the Hedge planting um Ryan can you just
go back to the previous slide please one
block plan which is I appreciate is very
difficult for members to see so Li block
Clan does indicate a uh if you can zoom
in a bit more mixed hedge planting along
those boundaries um which obviously is a
vegetation but that will be a planted
mixed hedge boundary because we haven't
got that detail the officer has
recommended as you'd have seen in your
committee report condition for requiring
full details so there are still um
control within the local Authority that
they would have to go through that
second the further stage to get that
Landscaping scheme which would include
details of lap planting so there will be
vegetation between the two and we will
get that detail as part of condition
for thank you
Sean and
if we went back to the photographs again
Ryan
showing Um Myrtle house at the top of
the
site that's yeah that's Myrtle house
there
um that's Myrtle house now now the site
that's a good photograph the site
opposite is the nursing home Rose Hill
Nursing
Home the where the red bit of line is
that you've drawn on that overgrown
piece on the right with a big tree that
is where the house is proposed to go
Myrtle house is a house over on the left
there across the other side of Robin's
Hill so there's quite a distance between
the two and howth house is a one on the
left you can't see that on this picture
but it's on the left and if there's this
planting scheme of a hedge that's look
go back there that's Myrtle house that's
the boundary I think councelor Christie
was asking me about that fence is the
boundary between howth house and this
actually this lawn area I think isn't
part of the application site the
application site is further to the right
I think that's correct isn't it Ryan
yeah pass that palade pass up bit of a
palisade this lawn area is to do with
Brar isn't it it's there and the
overgrown piece is the piece that's
going to be developed to the right
that's correct
yeah so
that gives it a better context I think
looking at
that as far as the letter that was read
out at the start from the people in
Mahana as Ryan has said I looked at that
when I saw the late letter coming
yesterday and as he said the upstairs
Windows uh first floor Windows to be
hung with privacy to frosted glass so
there's no other looking of Mahana and
one could argue that mahanna is probably
along with perhaps Cor tools if you look
at the Block plan the two closest hous
Myrtle houses across the road and on
quite a high elevation across the road
um and this is yeah the block plan so
I've never understood I've never
understood the issue of overlooking to
be honest on this site
personally I don't think anybody is
overlooked to any great
degree totally I agree with that
um if nobody else wants to
speak I should propose that we Grant
this
application I'll second it
chair thank you councelor Watson
councelor
lock C Watson was quicker on his b he
beat me to it again
oh thank you councelor lot well there's
nobody else wants to speak on this it's
been proposed and seconded that we Grant
this application Sandra can you go to
the vote please thank you chair
councelor bowon uh four councelor Brown
four
couny against councelor
craigy for councelor leather for
councelor lock for councelor mcgoff
against councelor Watson
or and councelor wisman
all chair that is eight for the
application uh seven for the application
sorry and two
against okay Sandra thank you for that
thanks for
that right we'll move
on our final application is application
1 obli
0457 2020 it's a full application
removal of of condition four uh
um who's presenting this one thank you
chair that would be
me who's me who's me oh James hello
James Jackson thank you chair and good
afternoon good afternoon members and
also members of the public my name is
James Jackson a planning officer at Tes
District Council I'm presenting uh item
7e of your agenda on behalf of the
planning officer Debbie Fuller um the
application number one oblak 045 7
oblique 2020 oblique
F uh this is a building at grid
reference 231 8791 378 uh for in in
plain English it's a site um Southwest
of the bradworthy um bu up area The
Proposal is the removal of condition
four pursuant to permission one oblique
0146 2019 F this is the time restriction
um the permission uh 014 0146 2019
grants Planning Commission for the
change of use of hardstanding an
existing building to provide vehicle
parking and storage use use class B8
including the addition of storage
containers excuse me uh condition four
of this permission is uh states that the
premises shall not be used except
between the hours of 0800 to 1900 Monday
to Friday and 0800 to 1300 on Saturday
and no working on Sunday and bank
holidays the reason for that condition
is that in the interest of the
immunities of neighboring
residents uh it's understood that the
applicant operates a 247 vehicle
recovery service and now wishes to store
the um recovery vehicle at the site um
this condition obviously precludes him
from uh accessing that vehicle on on the
basis of a
247 operation under which his his
business operates so um here we have the
the location plan this slide shows the
application site in edged in red on the
left hand side of the slide uh the site
comprises the VH storage building and
its Associated area of
hardstanding uh also within the site is
a treed area to the north and east of
the application building uh the the
access to the public highway is also
shown on the uh that right hand side of
the the site there uh and between the
highway and the storage building is a r
Venture dwelling known as Littleford
Cottage uh the aial image on the right
hand side of the slide um just literally
shows the location of the site as you
can see as I said at the start it's to
the uh the southwest of Brad
Wy uh next slide
please thank you um this is the front
elevation of the storage building and
you can also see the the concrete apron
around that and um area of hard
standing uh next slide
please uh this slide shows
the relationship in to some extent
between the B8 storage building and
Littleford Cottage uh there's
approximately 53 meters between the
building and Littleford Cottage although
the curtilage of the the cottage is is
closer to the site uh the access to the
storage building passes within close
proximity to Li Cottage and it's
Associated cage and it's because of this
relationship with the Environmental
Protection Officer objects to the
proposed removal of this condition on
the basis of noise disturbance arising
from the use of the site any time of day
or
night um the comments are of the
Environmental Protection Officer is set
out on page 132 of your agenda and the
officer's discussion of this issue is
set out on pages 54 sorry 134 to 136 and
concludes that the proposal would cause
significant harm to the immunities of
the occupiers of Littleford
Cottage uh next slide please
thank you ran um this is the site plan
just shows photograph on the left shows
the treed area between the application
building and Li Cottage and the site
plan shows uh a little bit more detail
in terms of the layout of the site um
including a newly proposed Beach hedge
at the SES eastern
boundary next slide
please thank you this is the Just A View
From the taken from the access to the BH
storage building here you can see the
access road that leads up to building Li
pottage would be on the right hand side
um of this
shot and next slide
please and the planning considerations
um are the principle of development
character and appearance residential
amenity access parking highways and
apy um and your officer's recommendation
is that Planning Commission should be
refused by reason of the consequence
signicant harm to the residential
amenities of the occupiers of m Cottage
set out on page 138 of your agenda um I
think it's just also pertinent to note
the obviously the the ex examp
commission 0146 from 2019 obviously has
that time condition uh on there which
this application seeks to remove a
previous application which was granted
um in 2016 for the use of the site as
well also had a time limit condition on
there as well so yeah just to note
really that this time condition has been
in place for some years okay thank you
chair if there are any questions I'd be
um happy to to address them thank you
James well we've got two speakers listed
for this uh one is uh Vicky prance in
support of it is Vicky prance here or
not to speak to this I don't believe she
is chair so I think it'll be myself once
again reading the letter right yeah fine
thank you
Sean
uh yeah so this is the letter from Vicky
prant this submission is made in support
of our request for you to remove
condition for pursuing to permission 1
20194 HJ Wicket and co- business we
carry on the business of vehicle repairs
bradworthy and vehicle sales hosw worthy
with petrol sales at both sites the
business is family-owned it commenced
trading in 1923 has an excellent
reputation within the local community
and operates in compliance with all
relevant legislations standards we
employ 10 staff and where possible
Source goods and services from local
suppliers we serve over a thousand local
customers on our database and are the
only petrol station between bu and hosw
worthy we support the bradworthy
community in both the services we
provide and sponsorship of L school
football team the bow Team and young
farmers use of Lite we acquired Lite for
the storage of vehicles a number of
conditions rep placed on the change of
use from agricultural we have operated
within the conditions at all times
except on three occasions when we had to
recover vehicles that were dangerously
obstructing a road following a breakdown
or accident we have ceased anything that
might be in breach of the conditions the
access to the site has been resurfaced
to reduce the noise and dust caused by
Vehicles entering and leaving the site
we maintain the site and the enjoying
agricultural land to the highest
standards in compliance with all
relevant legislation and deer standards
the building can house the recovery
vehicle in 10 cars currently there are
three cars and the recovery vehicle in
the building ideally eight cars would be
stored in the building but the
restricted hours make this impractical
there are currently on average working
day four vehicle movements one in and
one out plus the recovery vehicle one
movement per day if the current
restrictions were lifted we'd be able to
increase the number of vehicles store to
eight would increase the number of daily
vehicle movements to eight per day
having 247 access to recovery Vehicles
would result in additional fre movements
per week mainly in the early
evenings Littleford Cottage we do
everything we can to be good neighbors
to everyone within bradworthy and assure
you that we have tried tocate the owners
of Littleford when entering and leaving
the site we are as quiet as possible and
do whatever we are doing as quickly as
quietly as possible in the past they
have sought to betray us as disturbing
their peace and quiet intruding on their
privacy and generally disturbing them we
can ass assure you that this is not the
case Littleford is an idyllic fat fatch
cottage in a challenging location it
front on the busy Main Road linking
bradby and Hosey and has little or no
front garden Littleford is on a sharp
Bend adjacent to a river in a small
Valley and so traffic from both
directions is descending a hill breaking
for a corner and then immediately
accelerating hard to gain Speed Ahead of
the impending incline the road carries
significant hgv traffic serving a local
feed mil a nearby anerobic digestor milk
producers and processes and hes will
remarket in addition to regular psvs
delivery vehicles and agricultural
traffic
in spite of this the occupi of little
foood purchased it in full knowledge of
the nuisance of the road and that the
thenen Occupy of the site used a
building as his personal residence and
operated a Reclamation yard a so-called
agricultural business there
interestingly without any access
restrictions by comparison to the road a
noise caus by operation of the site is
inconsequential our entrance is further
away from Littleford than Littleford is
from the main road if the site reverted
to its use as an agricultural storage
facility it would be far noisier and
would not be subject to any access or
external storage
restrictions local immunity our premises
in bradworthy are congested with
vehicles awaiting parts or P pending
approval for work to commence this means
that our spaces allocated for customer
drop off are full and customers have to
leave their cars in square we see it as
our duty to alleviate congestion in the
Square for both residents and the other
businesses operating bradworthy
further when parents are dropping off or
collecting people from Brad School the
square gets even more congested and risk
people's being involved in accident as
drivers negotiate the square customers
of the various businesses of Brad expect
to be able to park in the Square
removing condition four would be of
benefit to our business other businesses
in bradworthy and the residents of
bradworthy please support our request to
remove condition
four thank you chair thank you Sean um
there's one speaker now for it and ask I
see councelor Dart the ward members here
so councelor Dart if you'd like to give
us your presentation please and unmute
yourself thank you very much um I'll
keep it quite brief because it's been
long hasn't it a very long meeting um
right so thank you for letting me speak
on this one Bry as I'm sure you're aware
is a rare but fortunate Village because
within the torch District it boasts a
pub a carpet store a hardware shop a
butcher shop a grocery shop a post
office a furniture shop and a garage
which sells and repairs vehicles and
offers a breakdown service and still
sells fuel so many we so often we drive
through Villages these days and they
just have a for cour which effectively
is a ghostly remnant of a bygone era and
we don't want this for Bry it's
essential that we as as a council
Embrace and support all Enterprises and
economies and I'm sure you would all
agree especially in our rural areas
wickets have been an integral part of
bradworthy village for generations and
um they continue to support the village
in various ways as mentioned in the
letter sha read out um and they go over
and above simply repairing people's V
Vehicles the site at little Ford is
required to store C cust vehicles and
their breakdown truck and owing to the
current time restrictions they're unable
to use it for that which they intended
however they are nonetheless still
paying considerable business rates on
the site and back tax um they
demonstrate diligence by getting the
planning change from agricultural to
storage and distribution um so
everything was above board and legal and
yet in doing so effectively they've shot
themselves in the foot whilst I have a
degree of Sy sympathy with the
neighboring property um at little Ford
what the pictures at the beginning
didn't show you were actually the um
proximity of that Cottage to the main
road which is actually nearer than the
driveway into wickets um storage area so
I simply don't accept that the amount of
noise pollution caused by the lifting of
this time restriction would make a
significant difference to this property
which after all is cited where it is
right to the next to the busy Main Road
between Bry and
hosby wickets are desperate for Clarity
on how this site fits within their
business and recently in Heartland we've
lost um a really good garage um they've
shut the Heartland site and um have
relocated everything to bued it's so
easy for businesses to do that it makes
good business sense effect effectively
and I would hate for bradworthy business
to go the same way um there are many
options for this site if wickets were to
sell it or um somebody else was to have
it
um
effectively there is the potential there
to be a lot more invasive on the
neighboring property and I think that
wickets actually really respect the
proximity of the property um but they do
need access to their breakdown truck
247 and really the parish council would
and the residents of Bry would probably
appreciate the extra parking that it
created in the Square where they could
store their um customer Vehicles so to
me it's a no-brainer I'm sorry it it f
you know may slightly impact on this one
Cottage but frankly if you buy a
property next to a main road you're
going to get noise there's no two ways
about it so I would urge you to Grant
the lifting of this time restriction and
demonstrate please your support for our
rural Enterprises and economies thank
you thank you councelor Dart right so
it's open to the committee councelor
lock you're first to speak please sorry
chair could before we do that could we
just have a vote to extend the meeting
by the three hours please oh God yeah oh
yeah thanks Stacy if for remind us that
Sandra would you just take a vote
uh I'll propose it we extend so I'll
second it Council lock seconded it could
we take a vote to extend the hours
please of the meeting yes
chair Council Bon four councelor Brown
four councelor Christie four councelor
craigy four celor leather or celor lock
four canor
off that's
four councelor Watson oh councelor
wisman oh that's unanimous chair thank
you um thank you s for that lock yeah I
mean I gotten myself I was in the
bradworthy area the other day and I
thought well we'll go natur you find the
site um which we did um and I see that
new application um has got a plan to
plant a new beach head for additional
screening I'm quite surprised that
wasn't actually done in the previous
application but that aside I mean the
track is in excellent
condition um there is if there's no
cattle grid there so you won't get the
extra noise of you know driving over
cattle grid all the time and as counts
the dart said the cottage that have said
in the ejection is literally right on
the road so I do agree with C that it
would um free up car parking space in
bradworthy
square um so I would recommend approval
but I'm searching for a policy number at
this stage if anyone can help me out
with
that thanks Council loot councilor
mcgoff I wish I could help councel lock
out but she's most experienced on the
planet but I do second Council L
proposal this is very important for the
village and I hate to see the
restrictions on the economic growth to
businesses within the area of Tor itself
we see so many restrictions on
businesses and given the recent event of
covid Etc you know we need to support on
our business as much as we can so I
second Council proposal and I'm more
depositors is going to find this policy
thank
you thank you Council mcov uh Sean Sean
Harrington uh chair I just understand
from the officer that there was a
further letter that was going to be read
out to the uh committee members before
they make a vote um I believe that Lee
Officer James Jackson was going to read
that out and he discussed that with
yourself that's from Littleford Cottage
I believe that's correct yeah I did
reply to um to James to to Omit little
bracket two and three from that letter
because it it was some personal comments
derogatory personal comments that I
wouldn't have allowed at the plans
committee anyway but the rest of it all
right to be read out and makes the point
that the people in Littleford Cottage
wanted to make so James if you want to
read that out minus those two paragraphs
yeah certainly yeah thank you chair okay
so this is from the um the occupiers of
Littleford Cottage in in Brad Ry which
is obviously the the property adjacent
to the highway um dear members of the
plans committee uh we firmly believe
this application has nothing to do with
the applicants breakdown Recovery
Service in fact with think this is just
a cover story in order for them to gain
access to the site 247 for activities un
related to the main garage premises in
mil Road particularly on Sundays and
back holidays when the garage is closed
the letters of support indicate they're
already providing a 24-hour breakdown
recovery service this is also
questionable why access to the recovery
lry was not mentioned or included in the
previous two applications even though
there have always been time restrictions
in place we would now like to draw your
attention to the following facts in 2018
the allowed Lee toly LT conversions to
use the shed as a workshop for his
camper van conversion business for
several months we monitored this for a
few months gathering information and
photos before reporting the breach to
the council the applicants denied anyone
was using the site for any such purose
and told the investigating enforcement
officer niga Marshall that someone was
there carrying out resurfacing groundw
work that this was of course a blatant
lie and which we were able to
prove Tim restricted access access has
also been ignored by the applicants with
the site being accessed outside of the
specified hours on numerous occasions
including bank holidays use of their
recovery lry was not the reason for
accessing the site nor has it ever been
on Sunday's bank holidays due to the
rural location of the site and because
it is set back from the road and
therefore out of site the applicants
think they can do whatever they like
having read the letters of support for
the application it should be noted that
some of the supporters live as far away
as Oak Campton Barnstable bord and Kil
Campton these people have no absolutely
no idea what they're talking about or
indeed what goes on at the site what we
have to put up with and probably do not
even know where it is situated some have
described the site as being a secure
compound or a safe car park it is
neither of these the site has no
electricity therefore there are no CCTV
cameras no alarm system no lighting and
the gates of the entrance of the site
are simply closed not locked so given
the site's isolated rural tuway location
it would in our opinion be an easy
target for robbery during the day or
night and certainly not a secure
compound in which to store customer
vehicles or anything else of value we
also note that only one resident of the
square Katherine bolon has shown support
for this application in conclusion we
are asking the plans committee to refuse
this application based on the facts we
have given in this letter and not
deprive us of the small amount of
privacy we have currently the proximity
of our Cottage to the main road is
totally irrelevant because the road is
not the issue here we would however
point out that the road is Extreme quiet
during the night so accessing the site
for Recovery lotry purposes during
antisocial hours would undoubtedly cause
us a great deal of disturbance yours
sincerely Mr and Mrs G
Clark thank you James thank you chair
just quickly as well at the start of the
presentation there were two additional
comments I should provided a verbal
update on uh since the drafting of the
um officer report both of those uh
comments are in support of the
application um and rais the following
issues um recovery service is a useful
service within the village and that the
proposal will not increase local traffic
volume or noise thank you chair thank
you James okay uh councelor M you've had
yours say anybody else want to speak on
this
one well I'll have my say then um I did
look at this very closely and I noticed
the previous use of it as an
agricultural shed obviously could cause
a lot more issues
uh I would have thought with noise I do
accept that um parking of a heavy
recovery vehicle in the square in
bradworthy and customers cars waiting to
be seen to isn't an ideal situation and
I know the square in bradworthy is very
well used by customers come in and going
from the various businesses in the
Square I also notice and it does despite
the letter that James has just read out
for me one of the real considerations is
the fact fact that Littleford lake is
right on the main road and it is a busy
road that I accept that during nighttime
hours late at night it's probably
obviously a lot quieter as most roads
are but the fact that this business
needs to be able to access the breakdown
vehicle and bring cars back that they've
been broken down or in accidents and
parked safely securely somewhere um and
they are proposing to build it plant
this hedge along the boundary although
looking at the photographs it did look a
very well laid out area to me with a
good concrete road going in whether they
could put perhaps some acoustic fencing
along that boundary with Littleford lake
is another issue that could be raised
but I I honestly
think that the the detrimental impact on
Littleford lake is very minimal I would
argue if you lift this they've got to be
able to access the site if need be 2
o'clock in the morning or 10 o'clock at
night or 8 o'clock in the evening
um and you know for that reason I I'll
be supporting that we do lift uh this
condition councelor
Lo um I just like clarification from
Sean really whether we could ref um
approve it on policy
st7 development will be supported
accordance with a um to support rural
development and mppf 83 supported the
propit and Rural economy may be
sufficient
reasons uh thank you Council lot
application is to remove a condition
pursuant to a existing planning
permission um they would be re good
reasons for approval obviously the
officer has um has outlined our concerns
with regard to the being contrary to
policy dmo1 in terms of immunity um it
is open for committee members to have a
different view on that of
course
thanks Sean yeah well on
page
138 at the top of that page the
condition is there and it's full
and it does say which is considered to
significantly harm the immunities of the
neighbor and occupi well in all honesty
I don't think if this is listed it would
significantly harm the immunities of the
neighboring pro occupiers at Littleford
Lake I honestly don't believe that
if nobody else wants to
speak your opinion chair pardon I said
that's only your opinion it is my
opinion yeah do you want to speak on it
councelor Watson no no very enough right
well I'll move that we do lift this
condition for uh if somebody wants to
Second it I will second that but then
we've got to list reasons st7 and mbpf
yeah
okay it's been moved by myself and
councilor lock seconded it that we LIF
this condition four Sandra could you go
to the vote
please yes chair councelor Bouton yeah
four grants yeah councelor Brown four
councelor
Christie councelor craigy four councelor
leather four councelor
four councelor mcof four councelor
Watson four councelor wisman
or that's unanimous chair thank you
Sandra thanks for
that right we'll move on
then to appeal decisions on pages 153
to7 you'll note that we've got
we can turn the page sorry Chris could
we just had the reasons why ruio was
withdrawn I thought Sean was going to
read out a letter yeah sorry chair just
a point of order I'm G have to leave now
chair I need to get back to work sorry
all right thank you K by bye now um I
thought um Council lock I thought that
Sean said it's different to a planning
application lifting the condition we've
lifted it for the reasons and you no I'm
talking about I'm about Ruby Oak now was
withdrawn from the agenda last night and
I was going to read um a communication
out as to why it was
withdrawn I didn't hear that Sean did
you want to read out a reason for that
uh thank you C lot thank to you
councelor lever um I don't have a
communication to read out in full um
however we have been in communication
with the agent and the applicant in
relation to Ru o the application was
withdrawn with a view to resm itting
with additional information um which
should help clarify the applicant's
position um especially in light ofly
difficult times with covid and uh the
community use of lpol um so we will be
expecting that application to be
resubmitted shortly uh with additional
information that can be
considered okay Sean thanks for that
thank
you right the the appeal decision summar
is there uh land at Reeds Farm Beford
has been
allowed
um cost on appeals at item nine on the
agenda there are no cost awarded on on
appeals delegated decisions item 10 on
the agenda you've got the two delegated
agmb decisions there uh one was approved
and one was
refused item 11 on the agenda is
planning decisions on page
159 these are delegated in the
main
160 page
161 162 yeah can
I councelor Christie could just say
something about the one halfway down
proposed toilet facility which one it's
uh one stroke
0443 on page page 162
162 toilet facility is it since within's
Church yeah I see that's put in by
litland Parish Council um we actually
had a bford council meeting last night
where St Mary's in bford has applied for
some money from us and our town Clark
has found out that Parish councils must
spend any money on churches I hope they
know about that yeah we've had that at
Northern too yeah with the church the
Parish Church in Northern of course they
can apply it may may not be that the
parish council are going to pay for it
but they can make the application of
course uh
163 and over the page 165 164 sorry and
you'll see there are two there that were
refused yeah you have councelor
Pennington's got his hand up for you oh
coun
Pennington thank you chair just to say
the litland parish council it was L
Parish church it was a mistake by the
planning office in bford that uh
um is C that so it wasn't an application
by litland Parish Council for since
withens it was litland Parish church
thank thanks for clarifying that
counselor
Penington okay uh right that's it
um I declared the meeting closed it's
been a long one but can members it's
half past one now can members hold on
because Sean's going to give us the
update that counselor Christie asked for
at the
start so if you just hang on for a
little while uh while we say goodbye and
thank you to all those who've been on
YouTube watching and thank you for all
the members of the public who've
contributed to the discussions this
morning